Nice.
Og.
Wird mal wieder Zeit hier.
Die Twitch-Settings sind auch jedes Mal irgendwie anders.
Ich versuche gerade die Emotes zu finden.
Aber keine Chance, Alter.
Settings.
Partner.
Da sind die Emotes bestimmt.
Nee.
Alter, wo sind die Emotes hin?
Und was will Twitch von mir?
Ich soll ein DAX7-Text-Interview machen.
What?
Alter.
Kann nicht mal irgendwas einfach so funktionieren, ohne dass man da offen irgendwas nicht findet und was machen muss?
Moin, Max.
Was muss ich machen?
Twitch sagt mir gerade auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Moment.
DAX7-Text-Interview soll ich machen, weil...
Please complete the text-information-interview fully.
Hä?
Das habe ich doch alles schon mal gemacht.
Warum muss ich das jetzt noch mal machen?
Go to Interviews dauert nur fünf Minuten.
Ja, ganz bestimmt dauert das nur fünf Minuten.
Das dauert fünf Minuten, wenn du drei Stunden lang irgendwelche Dokumente gesucht hast wahrscheinlich.
Habe ich jetzt keinen Bock drauf.
Ich mache jetzt kein DAX-Interview.
Muss ich nachher machen.
Okay, was?
Twitch, Twitch, Twitch.
Was passiert, wenn man das DAX-Interview nicht macht?
New EU Regulations require EU...
EU...
Alter, ich kann aber ausreden.
Ich kann halt sprechen, Mann.
EU.
Ich sage EU, okay?
Based Creators to complete a five-minute DAX-Interview.
Was?
Neue EU Regulations.
Die EU geht mir auch im Prinzip eigentlich nur auf den Sack mit irgendwelchen neuen Regulations.
So.
Ne, das mache ich jetzt nicht.
Da habe ich echt keinen Nerven drauf.
Danke für den Sub.
Huge Subscription.
Ich habe richtig krass viel gefressen vorhin, Leute.
Massive.
Nachdem ich wieder ein bisschen abgenommen habe, habe ich mir gedacht, das kann ich ja wieder zunehmen.
Hehehe.
Jetzt...
Ich habe mich heute Morgen auf die Waage gestellt und ich hatte...
Ich war gar nicht darauf vorbereitet, mich da irgendwie groß zu wiegen, ne?
Also normalerweise wiege ich mich nach dem Aufstehen in Unterhose, nur dass das irgendwie immer vergleichbar ist.
Vorhin habe ich mich gewogen nach dem Frühstücken mit Jogginghose und Hemd und so schon an.
Da hatte ich ganz knapp 91, also 91,2.
Also ich habe...
Also ohne Scheiß, Leute, das...
Gerade das Fahrradfahren hat echt nochmal viel gebracht mit...
Mit Gewicht...
Nee, nee, nee.
Keine Nudel mit Lachs.
Heute gab es Nudel mit Tomatensauce.
Oh, der Iron...
Der Iron Champ ist am Start.
Was?
Den.
Den brauchen wir jetzt.
Ich mache mal kurz Update.
Ich glaube, es hat sich einiges an Packages getan in letzter Zeit.
Naja.
Gruppen.
Leute, ich habe Zeug hier installiert auf meinem Arch-Dinux.
Ich weiß nicht mal was...
Was ist ein Gruppen?
Ach nee, Moment.
Ist es GU-PNP oder ist es Gruppen?
Gruppen.
Es ist wahrscheinlich eher GU-PNP, also GNU Universal Plug & Play.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Was ist...
Gruppen...
Ist...
Object Oriented Framework for Creating...
Ah, UPnP Device.
Ey, what the fuck?
Was habe ich alles installiert, man?
Gruppen.
Okay, ich weiß nicht.
Irgendwas...
Ich kann ja mal ausprobieren.
Ach ja, Leute.
Ich kann heute nicht richtig tippen.
Weil...
Ah ja, es breakt, weil...
Gruppen ist gebraucht bei...
Gruppen.
Ja, ach nee.
Da wäre ich jetzt nicht drauf gekommen, Alter.
Und ansonsten...
What?
Okay, nur dass ich das richtig verstehe.
Ich kann GU-PNP nicht deinstallieren, weil es von GU-PNP-IGNT gebraucht wird.
Und auch von LIP-GU-PNP.
Okay, und was ist das?
Ich frage mich nur, wer das installiert hat.
Ich nicht.
A library to handle UPnP-IGD-Portmapping.
Alles klar.
Jetzt ist es mal Bescheid, oder?
Jetzt ist alles klar.
Also, okay.
Ich weiß, was die mir sagen wollen.
Universal Plug & Play.
Das ist diese Geschichte mit...
Wir machen dynamisch Ports auf.
Im Zweifelsfall auch nach außen.
Aber...
Oder war das Media-Streaming?
Ich blick's grad nicht.
Ich weiß grad aus dem Kopf nicht.
Könnte auch Media-Streaming...
Oder war es einfach beides?
Egal, ich lass das einfach mal installiert.
Ich weiß nicht, warum ich's installiert hab.
Aber...
Naja.
Hat einen Sinn.
Leute, wir machen heute ein bisschen Proggers im Stream.
Aber ich kann nicht richtig...
Was macht eigentlich Tremoji?
Hat Tremoji eigentlich die neuen Sachen?
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, wie es aussieht.
Tremoji wurde zuletzt geupdatet im Januar.
Und was macht dieser...
Okay, Unicode 15 haben sie noch nicht geschafft.
Und was macht dieser Tremoji-Fork?
Gibt's da irgendwas Neues?
23. März.
Na, das bringt mir jetzt auch nix.
Okay.
Ja, jetzt war's.
Seriously, was für nen Emoji-Font soll ich eigentlich benutzen unter Linux jetzt?
Ja, der Titel ist auch nicht von mir.
Joho27, danke schön für den Sub.
Und Artenoxeto, Leute, hier alle am Stahl.
Danke schön für den Sub, Leute.
Pogu.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Und zwar...
Du meinst das HTTP von Google?
Nee, groß angeschaut nicht.
Ich weiß, was es ist.
Ja, aber...
Also, naja, noch nicht mal wirklich.
Ich weiß nur, dass es diese Google-HTTP-Geschichte ist.
Was für nen Emoji-Font verwende ich jetzt eigentlich gescheit unter Linux,
seit Tremoji suckt?
Also, ich meine, noch geht Tremoji, ja.
Aber beispielsweise das allerwichtigste Emoji,
nämlich die Gans,
die gibt's nicht.
Aber Noto...
Das ist so hässlich.
Ich mag die überhaupt nicht.
Guck mal.
Äh.
Moment, das sind nicht...
Nicht die richtigen, ne?
Ich mag die Noto-Emojis überhaupt nicht.
Okay, Linux-recommended-Emoji-Font.
Gibt's da...
Gibt's da irgendwelche...
Hi-Fat-Reddit-Commons, die so ein Jahr alt sind, ungefähr?
Tools, anytime, ja.
Ja.
Also, voll...
Für'n Arsch, eigentlich.
Ja, Tremoji suckt halt.
Ja.
Ich mag Noto-Emoji nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Also, ich persönlich find Tremoji mit Abstand den hübschesten Font.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt irgendwelche Tremoji-Patches.
Da gibt's doch garantiert Leute, die da schon,
auch wenn man das nicht darf,
die neuen Icons reingepatcht haben, oder?
Oder auch nicht?
Er meint, das geht ja nicht.
Das geht ja nicht.
Du darfst dir die neuen Bilder nicht mehr verwenden,
weil die Bilder mittlerweile von Twitter,
seit Elon am Start ist,
dürfen die neuen Emoji-Bilder,
von Twitter nicht mehr benutzt werden,
für irgendwelche Fonts.
Nee.
Nee, nee, heute nicht.
Ich war gestern ein bisschen,
ich war gestern wieder ein bisschen Fahrrad fahren,
und heute einfach nur eineinhalb Stunden,
so ein bisschen durch den Wald laufen.
Aber nicht rennen.
Einfach nur laufen.
Man darf ja nicht mehr.
Das ist, das ist ja das Dumme.
Die, die haben ja...
Deswegen, deswegen,
deswegen hebt dieser Fork wahrscheinlich auch nicht ab.
Was ist denn das?
Fleemoji.
An Emoji-Giftpicker.
Was man hier alles findet, ne?
Was?
Was ist das?
Ple...
Fleemoji.
Advanced Emoji-Picker for Linux, Windows and macOS.
Ich dachte auch GIF.
Ach so.
Ach, im Prinzip sowas hier, was ich schon hab.
Nur das ist, das, das ist bestimmt Elektron-based, Leute.
Wollen wir wetten?
Elektron-based.
Im Zweifelsfall 450 MB RAM für einen Emoji-Picker.
Und man kann GIFs picken.
Immerhin.
Nee, Dart.
Flutter ist es, Leute.
Es ist nicht, es ist nicht...
Elektron ist es.
Flutter MonkaS, Alter.
Flutter, Flutter Desktop.
Taugt das mittlerweile?
Nee, ich mag...
Ich...
Ohne Scheiß, der einzige Emoji-Font.
Den Windows-Emoji-Font.
Den hier, ich mag...
Also, okay.
Ich finde, der geht halbwegs.
Ich finde eigentlich, der geht.
Der ist nicht ganz so schlimm,
wie die anderen.
Ich mag Tweemoji.
Tweemoji ist der beste Emoji-Font.
Für mich, ja, doch seitdem ist das sehr Geschmackssache-mäßig.
Den alten Blob-Emoji-Font von Android,
den konnte ich mir, wenn es unbedingt sein musste,
auch noch angucken.
Also, entweder Tweemoji oder eben das von Mozilla.
Das ist ja, glaube ich, irgendein Tweemoji-Fork.
Die anderen, die aktuellen Android-Emojis mag ich auch nicht.
Die Apple-Dinger gehen auch ganz gut.
Aber gibt es den...
Ist der eigentlich Open Source, der Microsoft-Emoji-Font?
Gibt es den?
Gibt es den auf GitHub?
Fluent UI-Emoji.
Okay.
Ja, perfekt.
Aber die gibt es...
Fluent Emoji.
Gibt es die als Schriftart für Linux?
Aha!
Enable Windows 11 Emojis on Linux.
Jetzt kriegen wir es erklärt, Leute, wie es funktioniert.
Okay, das funktioniert ernsthaft.
Das funktioniert doch aber bestimmt nicht mit Color-Emojis, oder?
Leute, ich weiß, ich lasse mich gerade etwas sidetracken,
aber irgendwie bin ich da...
Man braucht eine eigene Font-Konferenz.
Gibt es den vielleicht?
Okay.
Ey, vor zwei Jahren, das ist alles Schrott, Mann.
Fällt mir alles nicht.
Das muss ich mir aufschreiben.
Vielleicht geht das echt, ne?
Also ganz im Ernst, das wäre tatsächlich ein Part von Windows,
den ich ganz gerne unter Linux verwenden würde, hier.
Die Emojis.
Die finde ich, die gehen echt klar.
Also für mich ist eindeutig,
wie Emoji.
Größer Apple-Emojis.
Ja, größer Windows-Emojis.
Und der Rest gefällt mir überhaupt nicht.
Hups, da habe ich mein Fahrrad aufgemacht.
Ja, was wollte ich denn noch sagen?
Eigentlich habe ich...
Was ist denn das für...
Gibt es jetzt?
Zigbee-Firmware-Fivehead.
Ach, ernsthaft?
Ja, das ist ja nice.
Moment, die konnten schon immer Zigbee?
Du kannst...
Wait a minute.
Du kannst mit der gleichen Hardware,
wenn die nicht...
Wenn die nicht explizit Zigbee unterstützt,
auch anstatt Bluetooth-Zigbee...
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Das ist ja nice.
Das muss ich mir speichern.
Ja, das muss ich mir merken.
Streamthema.
Das muss ich mir merken.
Das ist auf jeden Fall sehr nice.
Weil von meinem sind jetzt zum allerersten Mal
die Batterien leer im Bad.
Also insofern ich...
Also das Ding, warum es ganz cool wäre,
dass Zigbee zu haben ist,
weil ich dann kein Relay mehr für Bluetooth brauche.
Das heißt, er hat halt so eine beschissene Reichweite.
Die ist halt, ich weiß nicht,
drei, vier Meter oder so.
Und das reicht halt nicht bis zu der Home Assistant-Kiste.
Aber Zigbee ist natürlich viel, viel, viel nicer.
Oh, jetzt wird es aber richtig advanced hier.
Pairing, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Short for three seconds and enter pairing mode.
Okay.
Das ist nice.
Das muss ich mir angucken.
Das machen wir aber nicht jetzt.
Das finde ich tatsächlich ganz spannend.
Ja, das müssen wir ausprobieren.
Der Chip in den Teilen kann wohl Zigbee.
Was ich echt merkwürdig finde,
dass der Zigbee kann,
weil Xiaomi macht ja null mit Zigbee da drin.
Vielleicht hatten die das mal vor,
irgendwann zu enablen und haben gedacht,
na, wir machen das schon mal mit rein.
Man weiß nicht.
Stimmt, was ich sagen wollte, Leute,
ich kann heute gar nicht richtig tippen,
obwohl wir heute Progress-Stream machen,
weil ich habe mir den Finger geschnitten.
Heute Morgen.
Ich wollte einen kleinen Sensor aufmachen.
Und...
Da habe ich dieses Messer genommen.
Oh, das ist ja glücklicherweise nicht richtig scharf.
Ich habe so ein kleines, das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich auch,
iFixit Set.
Habe ich mir vor einer Weile mal gekauft,
so ein Set hier für so Kleinkram,
gerade für die ganzen Bits, die man sonst nicht so braucht.
Ansonsten habe ich ja wirklich mehr als genug Werkzeug.
Aber so gerade die kleinen Bits, diese Spezial-Bits,
die hat man normalerweise nicht so.
Guck mal, und da ist hier das da.
Mit dem Ding habe ich das hier.
Und dann habe ich mir den Finger geschnitten, heute Morgen.
Ja, das ist, das ist glücklicherweise nicht so scharf.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich stumpf, aber es ist, es ist scharf genug,
dass wenn du volle Pulle auf den Sensor drauf drückst damit
und versuchst, den aufzumachen, dein Finger drunter hast und abrutscht,
dir dann halt schön den Finger schneidest mit.
Ich mir, also ich habe hier von oben so einmal quer durch den Finger geschnitten.
Und das ist echt...
Das ist echt tief, also es hat erst einmal geblutet, wie Sau.
Bin ich ins Bad, habe Klopapier drauf gedrückt
und als es dann ein bisschen aufgehört hat zu bluten,
habe ich mal, habe ich mal mir das angeguckt und ein bisschen am Finger gewackelt.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ich am Finger gewackelt habe,
dann habe ich gesehen, wie sich das fast, fast so einen halben Zentimeter tief so auseinander schiebt.
So, oh fuck.
Jetzt habe ich ihn pflastert, jetzt habe ich alles zusammengedrückt wieder.
Ähm, Desinfektionsmittel drauf, drauf getröpfelt und pflastert drauf.
Morgen mache ich mal auf und gucke, wie es aussieht.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, das ist dann morgen wieder gut, ja.
Also ich meine, das tut, das tut bestimmt noch ein bisschen weh, aber...
Ich hoffe, das ist dann nicht gar so sehr im Arsch alles.
Ja, schon irgendwie, ja.
Nee, das kriege ich auch so hin.
Ich zeige euch, ich zeige euch gleich, was wir machen, beziehungsweise was ich, was ich gebaut habe und wir ein bisschen erweitern.
Kannst du noch alles spüren am Finger?
Ja, also Gefühl und so ist noch da.
Ich habe ja auch nicht unten den Finger geschnitten, sondern oben den Finger.
Da ist ja eh nicht so viel, so viel Fleisch.
Da ist ja eigentlich fast Knochen drunter direkt.
So, also, let's go.
Neu gestartet habe ich.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass ich alle deutschen Hoster, die ich bisher, und ich muss das, ich muss das einschränken.
Alle deutschen Hoster, außer Hetzner, die ich bisher ausprobiert habe, weil ich kann ja nicht von denen sprechen, die ich noch nicht ausprobiert habe.
Alle deutschen Hoster, außer Hetzner, die ich, die ich ausprobiert habe, beziehungsweise ausprobieren wollte, irgendwas haben, was mir extrem auf den Sack geht.
Ich meine, bei Hetzner gibt es bestimmt auch die ein oder anderen Dinger, wo ich mir denke, ey, das könnte man ein bisschen schöner machen.
Aber Hetzner hat zumindest, und kein Sponsor-Stream, Leute.
Ich habe schon eine Weile nichts mehr gemacht mit denen, aber es ist wirklich meine, meine persönliche Meinung dazu.
Das tut er einfach, für so kleinen Kram wie, lass mal eine VM bestellen.
Lass mal in der Server-Auktion was holen.
Und sowas, ist das wunderbar.
Und, wenn man mal das, das UI, gerade was die, das, das zum Anlegen von Loadbalancern und VMs angeht, das Webinterface vergleicht man mit Google oder mit Azure oder mit, mit, okay, mit AWS habe ich nicht so viel Erfahrung.
Dann ist das wirklich super angenehm.
Man kann das, man kann das aber auch nicht wirklich vergleichen, weil die anderen können viel mehr.
Aber, worauf ich raus will.
Ich habe gestern den Fehler gemacht.
Ich habe mir bei 1&1.
Ne, ist ja nicht 1&1.
Es ist, äh, doch ist 1&1, oder?
Ist Jonas nicht 1&1?
Doch, ich glaube schon.
Weil, also.
Oh nein, Postleitzahl liegt, Leute.
Ähm, was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen?
Ah, das Azure Webinterface, auch, generell sind die alle ein bisschen, ein bisschen Painschamp.
Jetzt wollte ich das, genau, also.
Ich wollte mir gestern Abend einen Server mieten.
Und, warum, warum dort?
Warum dort?
Weil?
Weil Hetzner explizit sagt, sie erlauben keinerlei Blockchain Cryptocurrency Zeug.
Das steht, also kannst du hier, kannst du hier, Hetzner, ja, da sagen die, ähm, da steht, Crypto, ja.
Following Actions sind verboten.
Operating Applications that are used to mine Cryptocurrencies.
So.
Das Ding ist, ich will keine, ich will keine Cryptocurrencies minen, bei, ähm, auf der, auf der Kiste.
Ich würde gerne einen Polygon Node betreiben.
Einen kompletten, 13 Terabyte großen Polygon Node.
Und den will ich, ehrlich gesagt, gar nicht betreiben.
Ich will einfach nur ausprobieren, wie gut das da drauf läuft.
Will, ich will das gar nicht langfristig betreiben.
Allerdings sagt Hetzner, keinerlei Cryptocurrency bei Ihnen in der Cloud.
Einen Polygon Node.
Nö.
Ja, den Support müsste ich fragen.
Aus zwei Gründen.
Also, aus einem Grund müsste ich den Support fragen.
Wenn ich einen Cloud-Server haben möchte, mit SSD dran, dann muss ich mein SSD-Quota erweitern lassen auf 15 Terabyte.
Allein deswegen müsste ich den Support fragen.
Aber wenn man auf Reddit sucht, äh, äh, guckt, der Support sagt immer, Cryptocurrency ist nicht erlaubt.
Was ist Polygon?
Eine, äh, das nennt, das ist die Cryptocurrency, beziehungsweise die Currency-Matic, glaube ich, wenn ich das richtig lese.
Äh, wenn ich das richtig im, im, im Kopf habe und richtig gelesen habe.
Und, also, so nennt sich, so nennt sich die, die Coin, die da drauf basiert.
Und das ist eine Blockchain, Polygon.
Nennt sich aber auch wurscht, was für eine.
Es geht, ich will den Node gar nicht lange betreiben.
Ich wollte es nur mal ausprobieren.
Äh, aus Gründen, weil mich die Performance da interessiert, auf den Kisten.
Und, geht nicht.
So, da habe ich mir gedacht, weißt du was?
Gehst du zu einem anderen Anbieter, wenn Hetzner das nicht erlaubt, gehst du zu OVH.
So, und dann, dann gehe ich bei OVH hin und da ist mir eingefallen, ach nee, die haben mich ja nie freigeschaltet, weil die unbedingt eine Ausweiskopie von mir haben wollen.
Nicht, dass ich großes Problem hätte, dem Provider eine Ausweiskopie zu schicken, aber ich habe keinen Bock, meinen Ausweis immer in der Weltgeschichte rumzuschicken.
Und wozu brauchen die meinen Ausweis?
Ich meine, seriously, ich will da keinen Public Service, sonst irgendwas drauf betreiben.
Ich will einfach nur ein Publiches, Publichen Server haben.
Auf keinen Fall.
Auf dem ich ein bisschen rumwursten kann.
Ja.
Na.
Echt?
Die wollen wirklich?
Okay, dann lasst uns mal kurz gucken.
Geht das?
Ja, das geht wirklich ohne...
Wann hast du das gemacht?
Also, ich wollte das letzt...
Also, bei mir ist das noch gar nicht so lange...
Vor einem Jahr oder so wollte ich das machen, glaube ich.
Jetzt nicht mehr.
Ah.
Gut.
Vielleicht sollte ich OVH nochmal probieren.
Habe ich aber gestern nicht ausprobiert.
Weil ich mir überlegt habe, okay, OVH hat mich wegen...
OVH hat mich wegen den...
Okay.
Nice.
Und will ich nicht mehr.
So.
Dann habe ich mir gedacht, okay, der einzige andere deutsche Hosting-Anbieter...
Achso, bei DigitalOcean habe ich es auch mal probiert.
DigitalOcean hat wie erwartet funktioniert.
Leider ist die Latency der Disks bei DigitalOcean richtig, richtig langsam.
Also, das Disk-Latency bei DigitalOcean ungefähr von...
Sieben, acht Millisekunden.
Und das ist extrem.
Passt mal auf.
Ich zeige euch mal, wie extrem das ist.
Ich bin jetzt in der VM lokal, ja?
Nur in der VM.
Sonst nirgendwo.
Also, noch nicht mal wirklich auf einer echten Kiste.
IOPing minus D minus W Punkt.
Guck mal.
Latency bei mir lokal in der VM sind ungefähr, ja, 270 Mikrosekunden.
Und bei DigitalOcean ist das Storage von der Geschwindigkeit, von der Latenz her, sieben bis acht Millisekunden.
Das ist richtig krass.
Kannst du nicht verwenden.
Bei Google und Microsoft ist es übrigens ähnlich.
Die...
Also, nur mal...
Ich erkläre euch das mal kurz.
Weil es, glaube ich, für einige, die vielleicht auch in dem Bereich arbeiten, echt mal ganz gut ist, ganz gut ist zu wissen...
Warum?
Warum soll ich mich sponsern lassen?
Man kann doch einfach, man kann doch einfach sich das kaufen.
Ja?
So.
Erinnert mich dran.
Ich mache gleich mit der IONOS-Story weiter.
Aber ich erzähle euch jetzt mal was.
Es gibt so drei, drei Faktoren, die so, die, die wirklich wichtig sind bei, bei Disks.
Oder bei Storage.
Ich rede jetzt nicht von einer expliziten Storage-Technologie.
Weil gerade im Cloud-Umfeld weißt du gar nicht so sehr, was da jetzt genau an der Stelle drunter...
Es gibt, es gibt drei wichtige Sachen.
Okay, Chat.
Wir machen mal Fifed.
Fifed.
Es, es gibt, es gibt was zu gewinnen.
Okay?
Ihr kriegt einen Sub, wenn ihr richtig liegt und noch keinen habt.
Was sind die, oder was sind aus eurer Sicht die drei wichtigsten Eigenschaften von einem
Storage?
Sagen wir mal, ihr habt eine Cloud-VM und ihr braucht Storage da drauf.
Das Speed ist mir zu ungenau.
Lese-Schreib-Geschwindigkeit ist mir vielleicht auch fast ein bisschen zu ungenau.
Ja, okay.
Sagen wir mal, das ist okay.
Ja.
Ja, ja, okay.
Integrity wäre das Vierte.
Also...
Ja, es ist...
Okay, es wurde mehr oder weniger alles schon genannt, deswegen kriegt jetzt keiner explizit
einen Sub.
Aber...
Ihr seht, ihr sagt nicht...
Also...
Geh, geh mal.
Haltbarkeit juckt mich im Cloud-Umfeld nicht.
Lese-Schreib-Geschwindigkeit ist das Erste.
Das ist, das ist tatsächlich wichtig.
Sagen wir mal, das bezieht sich hauptsächlich auf sequenzielles Schreiben oder sequenzielles
Lesen.
Halt...
Am Stück.
Du hast irgendwas...
Du hast...
Du hast irgendwas 2 Terabyte Großes, willst das draufschreiben, zack, bumm.
Soll einfach flutschen, 600, 700 MB die Sekunde Gigabit pro...
Gigabyte pro Sekunde.
Soll einfach flutschen.
Das ist...
Das Erste.
Das Nächste ist...
Ja gut, Größe ist auch nicht unwichtig.
Ram ist eigentlich Wurscht.
Ausfallsicherheit tatsächlich, da habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Integrität, ja, ist aber im Cloud-Umfeld meistens kein Problem.
Also das da irgendwelche Bits auf einmal nicht richtig sind, das kommt selten vor.
Iopsroduzent wird geze oilsимер topliniert.
IOPs und Latency, das sind also für mich auch die drei Sachen, also einmal das hier, IOPs und Latency und das Problem ist, was sehr viele Cloud-Anbieter haben und mit sehr viele ist eigentlich wurscht, es hat definitiv Azure das Problem und definitiv Google das Problem, wenn ihr bei Google, ich will jetzt Google, weil damit habe ich mich die letzten Wochen hauptsächlich beschäftigt, wenn ihr bei Google hingeht und denkt, dass nur weil ihr, Moment, so,
wenn ihr jetzt bei Google hingeht und denkt, ich kaufe mir, ja, da gibt es hier, also Balance Persistent Disks sind glaube ich Festplatten, so Oldschool-Dinger, also ihr denkt, ihr seid schon mal richtig nice und ihr kauft euch SSD bei Google, dann legt ihr eine VM an und sagt, ich brauche 15 Terabyte SSD, das geht glaube ich bis 65 Terabyte hoch, ja, hier steht es ja auch, also ihr sagt Google, ich brauche 64 Terabyte SSD,
und dann taucht bei euch auf eurer VM, auf eurem Server, taucht dann irgendwo Dev, SDA oder sowas auf oder SDB, SDC, wie auch immer, ganz normales Block-Device, das Problem ist aber, das täuscht, das sieht zwar aus wie ein Block-Device auf eurer Kiste, was ihr da von Google bekommt, es ist aber kein Block-Device, na doch, es ist ein Block-Device, es ist aber kein lokal angeschlossener Storage, das geht immer übers Netzwerk,
also sprich, wenn ihr euch sowas kauft hier bei Google,
dann ist es unter der Haube, ich meine, hey, ich war noch nicht bei Google im Rechenzentrum und weiß, wie die es wirklich aufgebaut haben, dann ist das irgendwie ein bisschen was in Richtung sowas, irgendwas in der Richtung, ich glaube nicht, dass es ISCSI ist oder EISGASI, wie es manche Leute aussprechen, aber sowas in der Richtung ist das, sprich, das ist Block-Storage über Netzwerk,
und Google selbst sagt,
dass das
ganz,
ganz Tolles, aber,
ja, aber sie sagen auch,
guck mal hier,
Performance-SSD, das täuscht, ist teuer,
wenn ihr euch da 13 Terabyte kauft, könnt ihr
über 1000 Euro im Monat für ausgeben, das ist
ordentlich teuer, also jede,
jede, kauft euch lieber ein paar
SSDs im Saturn anstatt in der Cloud,
so Geschichten, dafür hat es ein paar
Vorteile, du kannst es automatisch replizieren
lassen, zwischen verschiedenen
AdSets kopieren, zwischen verschiedenen Projekten kopieren
und sowas,
so,
das ist kein einzelnes Drive,
das ist doch das Ding, das ist kein
einzelnes Drive, das ist aus irgendeinem Drive-Pool,
wo du das bekommst, also von irgendeinem,
ja, von irgendeinem
Sahn kriegst du da was zoniert,
und
das geht halt über das
Netzwerk,
so, und jetzt, und jetzt kommt halt das
Ding, Google sagt hier auch,
das ist ganz toll für IOPS
und auch ganz toll für Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit,
und es ist auch ganz
toll für
Latency, aber
ganz im Ernst,
guckt mal hier, Single
Digit Millisecond
Latency, und
ich zeige es euch nochmal, was ich für eine
Latenz bei mir lokal auf meiner NVMe-SSD
habe, und übrigens, das ist eine VM,
auf Windows ist es nochmal die Hälfte
so hoch, ja, so,
ihr erkennt vielleicht den Unterschied,
bei Google ist es
ungefähr so, ja,
4-5 Millisekunden, also ich habe es getestet,
ohne Cache, direkt aufs Device,
auch so 6-7 Millisekunden,
und
ich habe es getestet, und ich habe es getestet,
und das ist halt, wenn ihr das mal
vergleicht, abfuck,
langsam, im Vergleich
zu wirklich richtig
lokal angeschlossenem Storage,
von der Latenz her, also mit
Latenz ist gemeint, wenn du
eine nicht gecachete
IO-Operation machst,
wie lang halt
der Zugriff, im Endeffekt,
nee, Zugriff ist das falsche Wort,
das Gesamtausführen
der Operation, im Prinzip von
Mach jetzt was, Storage
zu, hier hast du was, also die
die, also nicht
sequenziell, sondern die Latenz, wie lang es dauert
darauf zuzugreifen,
so, ja, kommen wir
gleich zu, Minister, so,
und wenn ihr Anwendungen habt, die
sehr Latenz
sensibel sind,
dann taugt das nichts,
dann taugt das
einfach nix,
und der Chat hat es ja auch schon
geschrieben, also
im Millisekundenbereich, 9 Millisekunden,
7, 8, das ist
richtig langsam, das klingt
nicht so schlimm, aber mal als
Beispiel, mal als Beispiel, stellt euch mal
vor, ihr habt, und das ist jetzt wirklich
ein praktisches Beispiel von meinem
alten Arbeitgeber, stellt euch vor,
ihr habt ein Storage mit
ganz vielen kleinen Dateien
drin, zum Beispiel, ihr habt
einen E-Mail-Server, ihr habt einen Mail-Server
mit 20
Terabyte E-Mails, ich weiß nicht, wie viel
es bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber gewesen ist, aber
das waren E-Mail-Bestände von
mehreren Jahren, ihr habt 20
Terabyte E-Mails, ich glaube, es waren
sogar noch mehr, 20 Terabyte E-Mails
und E-Mails haben halt das Ding,
das ist Text und oftmals relativ wenig,
du hast, du hast Milliarden
kleine
Furz-Dateien,
ja, und
das Ganze
wollt ihr
auf verschiedenen
Servern zur Verfügung stellen,
zum Beispiel,
also, machen wir es mal konkret,
ihr habt einen Storage, wo die ganzen
E-Mail-Sachen draufliegen, und ihr habt
drei Server, die das E-Mail-Handling
machen für die, für die Customer, die da drauf
zugreifen, und
ihr mountet euch das zum Beispiel rein
über NFS,
NFS ist auch so ein Ding, das ist extrem
Latency-abhängig, weil das ja
für jeden Furz, was es macht,
übers Netzwerk gehen muss,
dann stat auf die Datei
und wieder zurück, das ist
massiv langsam,
wir haben es bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber
ausprobiert, NFS in Azure zu machen,
es ist nicht benutzbar,
du brauchst für die einfachsten
Sachen, wir haben, wir haben easy
Sachen ausprobiert, so, äh, Auflisten
von Dateianzahl im Verzeichnis,
bei uns, lokal auf dem
NFS, keine Ahnung,
eine halbe Sekunde,
für ein paar Millionen Dateien,
in der Cloud, 53
Sekunden, das ist teilweise
echt, für Datenbanken, gerade wenn
du irgendwelche Datenbanken,
Replizierungsgeschichten machst und
sowas, das ist der Killer, das
kannst du nicht benutzen, das funktioniert
nicht, und die ganzen Cloud-Anbieter
haben ähnliche Probleme, verständlicherweise,
weil die den meisten
Storage über Netzwerk anbieten, so,
kommen wir jetzt mal wieder zurück, ich sag, ich sag
gleich was zu Local SSD, kommen wir
jetzt mal wieder zurück zu meiner Provider-Auswahl,
ja, genau, also kommen wir
wieder zurück zu meiner Provider-Auswahl, ich hab mir gedacht,
okay, am besten wär's
ja, also ich hab, ich hab's bei Digital Ocean
ausprobiert, ja, ja,
aber, aber Millisekunden ist halt wirklich
krass, ne, lokal angeschlossene
Informatik hat immer,
ich mein,
du musst dir allein schon mal die Länge der Kabel
angucken, lokal bei dir
auf dem Mainboard versus über
irgendein Fiber-Channel zu irgendeinem Storage,
ja, ja, aber das ist meist,
da reden wir ja trotzdem nicht von 7, 8
Millisekunden, genau,
sondern von halt immer noch
irgendwie im Rahmen, zumindest
bin ich dann zu Digital Ocean gegangen,
und hab mir das angeguckt,
dachte ich mir so, weißt du was, komm, easy,
gehst du mal bei Digital Ocean hin,
guckst mal, was die so haben, hab ich festgestellt,
okay, guck mal, die haben
Block-Storage, und da kannst
du dir, guck mal hier,
Pricing
Digital Ocean, da kannst du dir
15 Terabyte Storage holen,
ist überhaupt kein Problem, guck hier,
Storage, ja, Volumes
kannst du dir holen, überhaupt kein
Ding, 10, das geht noch
weiter, da kannst du 15, 15 Terabyte
eingeben, also, wunderbar,
hab ich gemacht, hab ich drangehängt, 7, 8
Millisekunden Latency,
das heißt,
die machen genau den gleichen Kram, so,
und dann bin ich auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen,
Max, weißt du was,
scheiß drauf, scheiß drauf,
hol dir einfach
irgendwo einen Server, fertig,
hol dir irgendwo eine Dedicated Server-Kiste,
Ruhe ist, wollte ich erst,
wollte ich erst zu Hetzner gehen, weil
Hetzner
hat wirklich coole Angebote
dafür, zum Beispiel,
Ausrufezeichen Hetzner, gibt's nix,
wollte ich zu Hetzner gehen,
hab gesagt, ey, Hetzner, wie wird's aussehen,
NVMe SSD,
ja,
nochmal ordentlich, NVMe SSD,
das Ding hier, Configure,
ja, ich nehm jetzt mal den erstbesten, den ich gefunden
hab, ich würde so
ein AMD-Ding nehmen, ja,
dahin soll's, Primary, und zusätzlich
bitte noch,
zusätzlich können wir noch 2 Stück hier,
nochmal, nochmal 2 Stück davon, bam,
so, bezahle ich nur,
könnt ihr euch mal vorstellen, nur
204 Euro im Monat, bei Google,
wenn ich mir bei Google
sowas professionieren würde,
in, in der Größe, bei Google
würde ich über 2000 Euro bezahlen
im Monat dafür, ist kein Witz,
also, wenn du, wenn du bei Google
ne, ne, ne Kiste professionierst,
mit 14 Terabyte Disk,
64 Gig RAM,
ordentlich, wie viel, wie viel hatten das, 32
Kerne, äh, CPU oder sowas,
da bezahlst du 2000 Euro im Monat,
also kannst du null hinten dranhängen,
bei Google, ja,
so, also, sowas dachte ich mir, ey, weißt du was,
Max, holst du dir sowas,
gut ist,
so, und dann hab ich festgestellt,
dann hab ich mal gesucht, bei Google hab ich festgestellt,
okay, Hetzner möchte keinerlei
Cryptocurrency und keinerlei,
ähm, selbst wenn es
nicht um Mining geht, keinerlei
Blockchain-Geschichten bei sich laufen haben,
so, und daraufhin
bin ich,
hab ich grad, okay, was machst du noch,
OVH hat mich abgefuckt mit ihrer Ausweis,
Kopie, gehst du mal zu
1&1, da hab ich nämlich
noch einen Account, da hab ich genau einen Server
laufen aktuell, einen
1 Euro im Monat-Server,
den hab ich mir irgendwann vor zig Jahren
mal geholt, und seitdem läuft
der, der macht nix, der läuft
einfach nur, aber dann Euro im Monat,
ohne Scheiß, ich hab ne
Public-IPv4-Adresse, die kann man
sicherlich nochmal für irgendwas gut gebrauchen,
und für 1 Euro im Monat
muss ich da nicht lange überlegen, den lass ich
weiterlaufen.
Hm.
Da bin ich hingegangen,
hab gesagt, okay, gehen wir mal
dahin, Dedicated Server Hosting,
äh, nicht Cloud,
was ist denn das hier, und da, also,
da ging das erste schon los,
die Seite von denen ist
abgrundtief Schrott.
Wenn du da was bestellen willst,
bricht das zwischendrin ab und die Seite
lädt nicht mehr und sowas.
So.
Also, hab ich mir das mal angeguckt, und irgendwann
bin ich dann draufgeguckt,
wo haben die das, guck mal,
du findest hier noch nicht mal was auf der Seite,
es ist so schrecklich, Server, okay,
Dedicated AMD Server.
Und da hab ich mir überlegt, weißt du was,
nehm doch dieses Ding hier, stellst du mal um,
und dann hab ich geguckt hier, okay,
ich hätte gerne was, was
ordentlich Kerne hat,
ordentlich RAM,
viel Storage-Möglichkeiten, Radiant Tracer,
danke für den Sub,
und, und jetzt kommt's,
aber auch einen ganz guten Boost für Single-Core-Performance.
Und meine Wahl ist dann,
glaube ich, auf,
ich glaube auf,
ach, kann man hier gar nicht mehr konfigurieren,
meine Wahl ist dann, glaube ich, auf den hier gefallen,
den ich jetzt hier aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht,
nicht auswählen darf, okay,
äh, meine Wahl ist dann auf den hier gefallen,
weil der hat zwölf Kerne,
128 GB RAM und bis zu 4,3 Boost.
Und da dachte ich mir so,
überhaupt kein Problem, kaufst du dir dieses Ding?
Kann man auch, kann man auch tatsächlich ganz,
ja, dieser Bestellvorgang hat schon mal gar nicht richtig funktioniert.
Das war das Erste, hat nicht richtig getan.
Ähm, man konnte aber hier eigentlich zusätzliche Platten auswählen,
warum geht das jetzt nicht mehr?
Hä, gestern konnte man hier noch verschiedene Platten auswählen.
Hä?
Wo ist es hin?
Gestern konnte ich noch zusätzliche Platten auswählen.
Warum geht das jetzt immer?
Plattenauswahl an Wochenende anscheinend?
Hä?
Ich hab mir,
das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn,
ich hab mir zumindest hier was zusammengeklickt,
mit,
insgesamt 21 TB Storage.
Vielleicht erst hier?
Hä, du konntest das hier direkt vorne aus,
anklicken.
Und das hab ich noch vom Handy aus gemacht,
da war ich nicht, war ich auch nicht eingeloggt.
Kann sein, dass die keine Platten mehr frei haben.
Was?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Rechten Zentrum, Spanien?
Was?
Wie kommt ihr darauf, dass ich in Spanien bin?
Äh, die Seite, die, pff, ey, keine Ahnung.
Zumindest, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Ich hab,
ich hab mich eingeloggt,
hab den Server dort bestellt,
und,
dann dachte ich mir so, ey, weißt du was?
Dauert jetzt vielleicht eine halbe Stunde, Stunde, dann ist das Ding da.
Und irgendwann nach drei Stunden oder so, bekomm ich eine Mail,
ähm,
rufen Sie bitte unseren Kundensupport an.
Und da hab ich mir gedacht, fuck it,
kriegt ihr halt kein Geld von mir.
Dann halt nicht!
So geil bin ich nicht drauf, euch 250 Euro im Monat zu überweisen.
Dann halt nicht, dann gibt's halt nix.
Ich mein, ich ruft, ich ruft, ich telefonier dann in der Weltgeschichte rum, um sowas Simples wie online einen Server zu bestellen, man.
Rechenzentrum, ich weiß nicht, hab ich hier, konnte man hier überhaupt Rechenzentrum, ja, steht doch da.
Okay, Baden, Baden, da will ich jetzt hin, Baden, Baden, perfekt.
Kann man, kann man hier mehr konfigurieren, ist hier vielleicht noch meiner frei, ne.
Warum kann man da keine Platten mehr auswählen?
Gestern ging das noch.
What the fuck?
Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Es war nicht Storage, okay, guck mal bei Intel, vielleicht gibt's bei Intel, vielleicht gibt's bei Intel mehr, ja.
Nein, ich hab das vom Handy aus noch ausprobiert, ohne einzuloggen.
Okay, das sieht, ah, hier kann man jetzt Platten auswählen, okay, alles klar.
Was auch immer.
Es ist halt, es ist halt echt, echt weird, ne.
Das, und ihr seht schon, die Bestellseite sieht jetzt schon ganz anders aus.
Die, gestern bei, bei AMD-Servern sah die Bestellseite noch aus wie hier.
Ne, jetzt kann ich auch wieder keine, doch hier, Speicher hinzufügen, hier geht's jetzt, guck.
Jetzt kann ich sagen, ähm, ach, hier, 7 Terabyte NVMe SSD, 2 mal NVMe SSD und hier nochmal NVMe SSD.
Oh, das wäre halt mega nice, weil, da hätte ich einfach, äh, was ist, 4 mal 7,6.
30 Terabyte SSD-Speicherplatz für, das ist sogar noch relativ günstig.
Bei Google bezahlst du dafür wahrscheinlich 4.000 Euro im Monat oder so, oder 5.000 Euro im Monat für so eine fette Kiste.
Das geht echt noch ganz gut, ich meine, nichts, was ich mir privat unbedingt kaufen würde, aber das ist, ist noch okay, ja.
Und das hab ich dann gestern bestellt, einen AMD-Server, keinen Intel-Server.
Ich hab gestern einen Server bestellt für irgendwie 150 Euro oder 250, 250 Euro im Monat.
Und dann ging's.
Und dann ging's einfach nicht.
Da, wo links das lila Feld konfigurierte Hardware best... was?
Ach ja, das ist auch geil an der, an der, an der 1&1-Seite, man kann nicht richtig zurück, guck mal hier.
Okay.
Okay, also anscheinend bin ich ja zu doof, das zu finden.
Lara, dann kannst du mir jetzt ja mal erklären.
Wo finde ich bei AMD-Server, ich seh da nämlich keinen Unterschied.
Wo finde ich bei AMD-Server jetzt die, wo ich das...
Das war alles konfigurierbare Hardware, guck.
Moment, das sind jetzt...
Sind das jetzt andere?
Hier, guck mal, konfigurierbare Hardware.
Konfigurieren.
Moment.
De...
I...
Hä?
Das hatte ich doch genau das gleiche, hatte ich doch eben angeklickt.
Ich hab doch genau das gleiche eben schon mal angeklickt, oder Leute?
Was?
Okay, jetzt blick ich nicht...
Oh, jetzt bin ich, jetzt bin ich extrem, extrem verwirrt, ja.
So, ich bin vorher auf Server.
AMD-Server.
Zur, zur Konfiguration.
SSD.
Und dann hab ich mir den rausgesucht.
Den da, den hab ich angeklickt, ne?
Hier, 64, hier.
Konfigurieren.
Weitere Grund, warum die Seite einfach sackt, ja?
Ja, sowas...
Sinngemäß hab ich mir gestern ungefähr sowas da bestellt.
So hier, so.
Äh.
Sowas hier.
Das, das, das hab ich mir gestern bestellt.
200...
Nee, das kann nicht exakt das gewesen sein.
Aber 250 Euro im Monat, ja?
Und danach...
Und danach kam, bitte rufen Sie unseren Kundendienst an, damit wir den Server bereitstellen können.
Da hab ich gesagt, nee, mach ich nicht.
Wenn ich's nicht auf die Reihe krieg, dann halt nicht.
So geil bin ich nicht drauf, zu euch 250 Euro zu überweisen.
Gut.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn.
Ich hab jetzt fast so eine Stunde geschwätzt.
Das wollte ich heute eigentlich gar nicht machen.
Zumindest...
Ja, ich hab natürlich immer alles bezahlt.
Ich hab sogar meinen PayPal-Account verknüpft, dass sie automatisch abbuchen können.
Aber, naja, was willst du machen?
So, jetzt kommen wir noch zu einer Sache, was...
...der Chat gefragt hat.
Warum keine Google-Lokalen-SSDs?
Das hat Gründe.
Erstens, weil für mich privat Google viel zu teuer ist.
Das sind eigentlich schon für den Sub.
Und sorry an alle, wo ich's vergessen hab.
Wenn ich jetzt ein englischsprachiger Channel bin, würde ich sagen, ich appreciate jeden Sub.
Ja, Leute, danke schon für die ganzen Subscriptions.
Also, kommen wir jetzt mal hier...
So, warum nicht lokale SSDs?
Erstens, weil Google für mich...
...privat viel zu teuer ist.
Bei Google kosten...
Also, die Kiste, die ich hier zusammengeklickt hab, bei...
Also, das da, ne?
So ein Ding.
Machen wir mal.
Leute, ich zeig euch mal, wie abfuck teuer das sind die...
War mal AX, waren das die ARM oder die AMD?
Ähm...
Epic.
Genau.
So, hier.
Bam, Configure.
Nenn wir mal das Fetteste.
Nenn wir mal das Fetteste, was es gibt.
Okay.
Fetteste, was es gibt.
4x2.
Grundreich, Gig in your face.
In Falkenstein.
Der ist sogar ein bisschen teurer.
Guck mal.
Falkenstein, Helsinki, sogar günstiger.
Für ein Kryptonode würde sich das...
Aber Headster mag keine Kryptonodes.
Ähm, so.
Rescue System free.
RAM, perfekt.
So, und jetzt...
Und hier kann man jetzt einfach sagen...
Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
So, zack.
751 Euro im Monat.
Für...
8x...
8x7,6.
Für...
Äh, 8x.
8x.
Möb.
Danke schön für den Sub.
Für 60 Terabyte Disks.
So.
Wir nehmen jetzt absichtlich mal eine super fette Kiste.
Dass ihr mal seht, wie ultra teuer Azure und Google sind.
Natürlich, es ist immer ein bisschen unfair, der Vergleich.
McD, danke für den Sub.
Ich gebe zu, es ist immer ein bisschen unfair, der Vergleich.
Weil, du kannst bei Google und Azure auch viel, viel mehr noch machen.
Ja.
Aber, es geht mir ja drum.
Ich brauche jetzt wirklich einfach fette Server-Hardware.
Und das Ding ist wirklich nice.
Du hast 128 Gigabyte RAM, 32 Kerne, ist noch ein Zen 2.
Aber, ist dafür egal.
57 Euro im Monat.
60 Terabyte.
So.
Jetzt kommt das erste Problem bei Google.
Bei Google kannst du gar keine lokalen SSDs in dieser Größe auswählen.
Das Maximale bei Google für eine, ja, normale, in Anführungsstrichen, VM, sind 9 Terabyte.
Wenn du 12 Terabyte SSD-Speicher haben möchtest bei Google.
Also, wirklich, richtig, echten SSD-Speicher.
Ihr müsst wissen, SSD, Persistent Disk und Local SSDs, das ist was anderes.
Das hier ist ein SSD-Storage, der über Netzwerk angebunden ist.
Der zwar auch als Block-Device bei eurem Linux erscheint, aber keine richtig, quasi, an euch, an die Kiste, wo ihr drauf lauft, angeschlossener Speicher ist.
Das hier ist, ja, in der jeweiligen Hypervisor-Plechkiste, wo deine VM drauf läuft, halt wirklich SSD-Storage.
So.
Du kriegst maximal 9 Terabyte.
Pro, äh, pro VM.
Und wir reden hier nicht von 9 Terabyte Platte pro, äh, 9 Terabyte Platte, äh, wo ich mir mehrere dranhängen könnte.
Nein, nein.
Man bekommt diese lokalen SSDs von Google.
Das ist super weird, Champ.
Man bekommt lokale SSDs von Google nur in 375 Gigabyte-Häppchen.
Und worauf sich diese 9 Terabyte beziehen ist, du hast ein Limit, wie oft du diese 375...
...75 Gigabyte-Häppchen an deine VM hängen kannst.
Und bei normalen VMs, die sich noch normale Leute leisten können bei Google, ist dieses Limit 24.
So, und 375 mal 24 ist 9 Terabyte.
So setzen sich die 9 Terabyte zusammen.
Also du kannst maximal, das ist limitiert, mehr geht nicht, du kannst maximal 9 Terabyte lokale SSDs an eine normale VM in Google anschließen.
Google selbst sagt...
...dass bis zu 12 Terabyte gehen.
Und jetzt passt mal auf, ich zeige euch das jetzt mal.
Weil die müssen wir nehmen, um das hier vergleichbar zu machen.
Also bei Hetzner, wohlgemerkt, würden wir kriegen...
...60 Terabyte Speicher, 128 Giggramm und 32 Kerne.
Jetzt machen wir mal den Google-Preisrechner.
So, jetzt haltet euch fest.
Ich hoffe, man kann das überhaupt im Google-Preisrechner abbilden.
Bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher, ob das da geht.
So.
Also.
So, was wir brauchen, äh, Number of Instances 1.
So, du musst, du musst, äh, C3 nehmen dafür.
Und du brauchst die SSD, ah, die SSD-Config ist hier gar nicht zum Auswahlen.
Sehr schön.
Nice.
Ist ja schon mal der Preisrechner...
...useless.
Aber das macht nichts, man kann...
...was ähnliches auswählen.
C3-LSSD heißt der Krempel bei Google.
Ja.
Also, da gibt es, da gibt es, da gibt es dann zum Beispiel sowas wie, da gibt es dann C3, das ist, das ist die einzige Kiste, die es gibt bei Google, die bis zu, äh, bis zu 12 Terabyte lokale SSDs haben kann.
Also, C3, C3 Standard 127, ja, äh, es ist halt schon ein bisschen, ein bisschen Oversized, ja.
Und jetzt, und jetzt...
...und jetzt noch kann man noch hier irgendwie lokale SSDs, ja, Boot-Size 40 Gig.
Kann man Local SSDs, äh, Local SSDs kann man hier dran machen.
Sieh, äh, 32 mal 365, okay, nice, perfekt.
So, äh, es, es kostet mich einfach 10.000, äh, 9.000 Euro im Monat.
Also, um, um was zu bekommen bei Google, mit dem ich ansatzweise was anfangen könnte, muss ich einfach 10.000 Euro im Monat bezahlen.
Ja.
Äh, äh, weniger RAM geht nicht.
Das ist ja der Trick bei Google.
Weniger RAM geht nicht.
Die einzige, die einzigen Kisten, wo du 12 Terabyte SSDs anschließen kannst, sind diese ultra fetten 176 Kerne 1,4 Terabyte, was auch immer RAM Kisten, man.
Bei Azure ist ähnlich.
Bei Azure ist, glaube ich, nicht ganz so krass.
Bei Azure bin ich mir aber aus dem, äh, aus dem Kopf nicht so sicher, wie dort die Local SSD Option heißt.
Also, es ist mega teuer, Leute.
Es ist ultra teuer.
Und deswegen ist manchmal Google nicht, äh, äh, äh, äh, also, große Cloud-Anbieter nicht unbedingt immer das Beste für alles, was man, was man machen will.
Hast du halt eine Network-SSD, ja, aber da geht's doch grad drum.
Was ist ohne, ja, ich brauch's aber mit Local-SSD.
Ja, wir könnten mal, wir könnten mal gucken, was es mit, mit normaler SSD kostet.
Also, normale, normale 4M sind auch relativ teuer.
Nehmen wir mal was Entsprechendes hier.
128 GIG RAM.
Ja.
Dann brauchen wir aber keine C-Maschine, sondern nur eine N.
Ja, N.
Dann nehmen wir mal N32, 32, oder 32.
Das ist doch ganz gute, ganz gute Kombination.
Äh, dann machen wir Local-SSD, Local-SSD 0.
Können wir dran machen.
Und Disk, ja, persistent Disk, machen wir sogar nur Zonen-Persistent-Disk, ja, 12, 12, äh, Terabyte, ja, Ad.
Das ist dann schon mal ein bisschen
Da ist aber die VM jetzt gar nicht dabei
Ah, okay
Hier bezahle ich immerhin für das gleiche
Was ich bei Hetzner bekomme
Nur noch 1750 Dollar
Klickt ihr mal eine gebrauchte Kiste auf Servershop24
Das machen wir jetzt gleich
Es ist zwar überhaupt null das, was ich heute machen wollte
Aber machen wir jetzt trotzdem
Also es ist schon
Wir können es auch übrigens auf Euro umstellen
Also es kostet
Also vergleichbar, sagen wir mal so
Das, was ich bei Hetzner kriege
Für 750 Euro
Bezahle ich bei Google halt
1655 Euro
Und dazu kommt
Dass die SSDs hier
Nicht benutzbar sind für das, was ich haben will
Das ist halt schon krass, ne
Was das kostet
Bei Hetzner ist das lokal angeschlossen
Über NVMe
Das ist genau das, was ich brauche
Wenn man die Features braucht
Die diese Cloud-Disks bieten, ja
Dass du es automatisch replizieren kannst
Dass du das kopieren kannst
Zwischen Projekten
Dass du es zwischen Rechenzentren easy kopierst
Dann ist das alles fein, ja
Oder automatische Backup-Pläne
Das ist alles top
Aber in dem Fall will ich das alles nicht
Ich will Performance
Ach ja, und ein Nachteil, den ich noch gar nicht erwähnt habe
Bei den Local-SSDs ist
Die werden gelöscht, sobald du deine VM ausschaltest
Also Reboot ist fein
Reboot ist gut
Aber sobald du eine VM Power-Off machst
Wird die SSD gelöscht
Das ist vielleicht auch nicht ganz so praktisch für alles, ja
Deswegen wäre halt so eine Kiste bei Hetzner mega nice dafür
Aber der Hetzner mag ja keine Blockchain-Sachen bei sich
Wie groß ist die Performance?
Es kommt drauf an, was du machen willst
Wenn du einfach nur IOPS brauchst
Also hohe IOPS
Und vielleicht hohe Sequenz-Sachen
Hohe sequentielle Übertragungsrate
Würde ich fast sagen
Fährst du mit den Netzwerk-SSDs
Im Großen und Ganzen vielleicht sogar besser
Weil du die ganzen Features dazu hast
Und die halt
Darüber raus skalieren
Was eine Disk bieten kann
Weil du auf irgendeinem fetten Storage rauskommst
Also für normale Anwendungsfälle
Sequentielle Übertragungsspeed
Richtig fette IOPS
Ist das wahrscheinlich sogar besser
Du nimmst die ganz normale
Übers Netzwerk angebundene SSDs
Die dir jeder Cloud-Anbieter anbietet
Wenn du aber geringe Latency brauchst
Pro IO-Operation
Dann ist lokale SSD das Master-Dinge
Ja, genau
Leider will das Hetzner nicht
So, und jetzt machen wir das mal
Was der Chat noch vorgeschlagen hat
Server Shop 24
Da hab ich ja nie was
Used and Refurbished Servers
Okay, wir klicken uns was zusammen
Alles klar
HP
Dell
Haben wir noch Lenovo?
Äh, haben sie noch
X
Das ist ja richtig antik
X3650, ey
Wobei, die sind
Die Dinger heißen heute immer noch so
Ach, M5, das ist die Generation
Wahrscheinlich, oder?
Ich kenn mich bei der Bezeichnung nicht aus
Ähm, ich kenn auch die alten IBM-Dinger
IBM
X äh 37
55 und wie die Dinger alle heißen
Ähm, ich kenn auch die alten IBM-Dinger IBM X äh 37 55 und wie die Dinger alle heißen
Ähm, ich kenn auch die alten IBM-Dinger IBM X äh 37 55 und so was
IBM X 3755, gab's sowas?
Ja, genau
Da hatten wir viele
Da hatten wir viele, wo ich, ähm
Wo ich beim Provider gearbeitet hab im Rechenzentrum
die paar Jahre
Da hatten wir ganz viele von den X 3755
Ja, aber ich glaube M5 dürfte wahrscheinlich die Generation sein
Weil das ist definitiv zu neu
DDR 4 und die CPUs
Als dass ich damals was schon hatte, ne?
schon damit zu tun hatte. Die gab es schlechthin ergreifend
auch gar nicht.
Also, lasst uns doch mal was zusammenbauen.
Haben die
AMD?
Irgendwie hätte ich gerne mal
eine AMD-Kiste.
AMD Epic.
Okay, machen wir mal preis-leistungsmäßig
ein bisschen was. Nehmen wir mal HP.
HP, DL,
DL380, das sind
zwei AE-Kisten, Gen 8.
Das ist garantiert noch Intel.
Vielleicht sind die
neun? Haben die neun AMD
drinne?
Links unten kannst du konfigurieren.
Wo jetzt?
Wo? Ich seh nix.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich wollt mal gucken, ob es die gibt.
So, also da haben wir ein bisschen ältere.
Zwei Xeons, acht
Core, sechs. Oh, die sind aber schon
ganz schön alte Dinger hier.
Sassdisk und so.
Aber letztendlich ist es...
Ist es wurscht? Kann man auch
SSDs anschließen? Okay, nehmen wir mal ein bisschen was
Neueres. Nehmen wir mal zehnte
Generation.
Ah ja, okay, da kann man
auch wahrscheinlich die Größe
der
Disks,
also 8x2 reicht der Dicke.
DL385 ist
AMD. Aha.
Interesting.
Nice, was
kriegen wir denn hier Schönes? 32
Gig RAM unter den
Marken steht. Components.
Ah, ne, das ist
Zubehör. So, nehmen wir mal
hier so ne Kiste.
2x AMD EPYC 24.
Das ist eigentlich viel zu krass, aber
warum nicht? Nehmen wir mal
24 Kerne.
2,8 G. Ein bisschen höher taktbar
wäre nicht schlecht, aber schauen wir mal.
Ah, zack, bumm.
5000 Euro und jetzt kann man
das konfigurieren. Kann ich mir noch ein paar SSDs reinstecken
lassen? Ich will eigentlich
keine AMD. Ich hätte gerne SSDs.
Wenn das möglich ist.
SSDs?
SSD Upgrades. Jawoll.
8x
Gigabyte. Das ist ein bisschen wenig.
Können wir vielleicht so ein bisschen
außerdem sind das nur SATA.
Ja, das.
Okay, ganz ehrlich.
Das wird, Server Hardware
kaufen lohnt sich bei sowas eher
nicht.
Ich sag mal so, was heißt eher nicht?
Ich meine 750 Euro im Monat
nach ungefähr einem Jahr.
Hat sich das auch wieder gerechnet.
Wobei ich ganz ehrlich, wenn ich so eine, wenn ich
wirklich so einen Blockchain Note Polygon
Note daheim betreiben
wollen würde, an irgendeinem
Anschluss daheim, dann würde ich mir ganz
simpel irgendeine Risen
Kiste zusammenbauen und
ordentlich SSDs dran hängen.
Fertig aus.
Stromkosten kommen auch noch dabei, wenn du es daheim
laufen lassen willst, was ja eigentlich hoffentlich kaum einer
macht.
Danke für den Sub. Excellent IQ Boost
für alle hier.
Falls ihr irgendwas übersehen habt, Leute,
postet es einfach nochmal.
Ja, jetzt habe ich eine Stunde
im Kreis gelabert. So sah es
bei mir gestern aus, als ich nach
Serverkonfiguration gesucht habe. Und leider
macht Hetzner nicht mit, sonst hätte ich mir so eine
Kiste hier bestellt. Ein bisschen kleiner.
Ein bisschen kleiner hätte ich bestellt, ja.
Leider mag Hetzner keinerlei
Blockchain
Technologie. Lass uns
nochmal schnell noch gucken, was hat denn OVH zu bieten?
Bring ich das durch,
oder? OVH waren die, wo es RZ
gebrannt hat vor einem Jahr ungefähr, oder?
Oder waren das andere?
Ne, oder war das Netcap? Netcap hat's
ge... Ne. Ne, OVH
ist...
Ja. Okay, was haben die denn so zu bieten
mittlerweile? War die Seite schon immer
nur...
Immer nur auf Englisch? Ja, anscheinend.
So.
Ja. Lass uns doch mal
nochmal Just For Fun gucken.
Was würde Bare Metal und VPS?
In Frankreich hat's bei den
ge... Frankreich hat's auch bei Google letzten
Jahrs gebrannt. Google hatte letzten
Jahr in einem Rechenzentrum in Frankreich,
hatten die da nicht drei Sachen zusammen?
Erst Überschwemmung,
dann Stromprobleme
und dann noch ein Brand oben drauf?
Die hatten irgendwie, die hatten irgendwie
drei Katastrophen in einem Rechenzentrum
am gleichen Dach.
Überschwemmung, Hochspannung und Brand.
Also nicht die hier, sondern Google.
Nein, keine Ahnung, hab ich noch nie benutzt.
Ja, genau,
das meine ich.
So, was haben die hier denn zu bieten?
Lieferung binnen
120 Sekunden.
Riese.
Dedicated Server.
Warum ist die Riese?
Der Riese, das war eine
Zombie-Map. Okay, soll Rise heißen
wahrscheinlich. Server
entdecken.
Entdecke unsere Server.
Machen wir mal AMD.
Storage NVMe.
Standort
Deutschland wäre nicht schlecht.
Game. Advanced.
Hier, was haben wir denn hier?
Storage.
Advanced 3.
Zwölf Kerne, sieben...
Das ist ziemlich gut.
Passt zu dem, was ich so haben will.
Ja.
Machen wir mal
128 GB rein.
Storage.
NVMe.
Kann man
noch zusätzlichen Storage reinhängen hier
irgendwie?
Weil im Software-Rate will ich die nicht haben.
Gut, ich kann selbst installieren und das
Software-Rate ausschalten.
Aber das ist ein bisschen wenig.
Ich meine, das sind nur 16.
Ich meine, da würde ich gerade so mit auskommen.
Aber
mir persönlich wäre es lieber,
wenn man sowas
fürs System machen könnte und ich dann mir noch
2x7 oder so zusätzlich dranhängen könnte.
Aber ich glaube,
das geht nicht.
Ich glaube, man kann keinen zusätzlichen Storage reinhängen mehr.
Muss man da vielleicht...
Kann man da vielleicht hier suchen
nach...
Aber eigentlich ist es mir egal, ob AMD oder Intel.
Kann man hier vielleicht sogar suchen nach
wie viel man attachen kann.
Nicht wirklich, oder?
Also sagen wir mal so, ich will
mindestens 12 Core
haben.
Advanced 3.
Was ist das da so?
Kann man da zusätzlich was?
Die sind innerhalb von 2 Minuten bereit.
Die sind nicht custom.
Ja, da ist schon was dran.
Das ergibt Sinn, was du sagst.
Ich meine,
im Zweifelsfall
wäre sowas hier echt
nicht verkehrt, gell?
Advanced 3?
Dann sagen wir mal
64 Gig. Okay, 64 kann man
schon noch machen.
64 Gig.
Und dann brauchen wir halt volle Pulle.
4x
3,84 TB.
Ich hoffe, hat jemand
hat jemand Erfahrung da mit OVH?
Kann man das Soft RAID
selbst konfigurieren?
Also scheiß drauf RAID 1,
sondern mach einfach
gar kein RAID und ich mach dann
selbst ein LVM oder sowas?
Das wäre mir
ganz sympathisch. Ja.
Kostet schon ein bisschen was, ne?
Kostet schon ein bisschen was.
Ist das...
Wie läuft denn das bei OVH?
Ist das minutengenaue Abrechnung?
Also kann ich das auch einfach einen Tag laufen lassen
und dann wieder löschen?
Oder ist man wirklich einen Monat
dran gebunden? Da wird man ja nicht so
schlau draus. Minuten oder Stunden
genau reicht mir auch schon.
OVH was?
Scaleserver. Jetzt
kommen die Kenner
hier. Scale.
Aha.
Boah, das sind... Okay, das sind
die richtig teuren Dinger.
Doubles, da geht's richtig.
16...
16 Core...
Okay, zeig ich mal her.
Soft RAID, soll mir recht sein.
Ach hier, Storage kann man zusätzlich auswählen.
Jawoll, genau sowas.
Es ist halt jetzt schon
ordentlich teuer, ne?
Wo seht ihr die Laufzeit?
Wo scrolle ich zu schnell? Wo steht das?
Without Commitment.
Without Commitment heißt doch im Endeffekt
ich kann das nach einem Tag
wieder wegschmeißen, ne?
Wenn ich es immer brauch.
Ach, die werden jetzt aber zusammengebaut, ne?
Moment, Setup Fee?
Ah!
Okay, das ist
weil das Custom gebaut wird, deswegen
Setup Fee.
Dann ist das wirklich nur was, wenn man's länger...
länger behalten will.
Dann war das andere tatsächlich gar nicht so übel.
Egal, genug jetzt.
Eigentlich wollte ich was ganz anderes machen.
Ich reboote
gerade noch mal meine Kiste.
Alle Updates gemacht.
Und dann erzähle ich euch noch was.
Während das rebootet.
Der Grund, ich habe euch noch gar nicht
den Grund erzählt, warum ich eine Polygon
Kiste betreiben möchte.
Polygon Node Kiste.
Also erstens möchte ich gar nicht
wirklich privat eine Polygon...
Node, Polygon Node betreiben.
Ich wollte das mal ausprobieren, weil
bei mir auf der Arbeit
wir experimentieren relativ viel mit
Blockchain Sachen gerade.
Und ja, fragt mich nicht was Versicherung
und Blockchain miteinander ist, darf ich euch
nicht so genau erklären, aber wir experimentieren relativ
viel mit Blockchain
Geschichten zur Zeit.
Und wir haben das Problem, dass
sowohl Azure als auch Google mega langsam
sind, was alles was
Blockchain angeht. Und das liegt zum größten
Teil daran, weil die Latenz auf die Platte
zu, zu
hoch, ich wollte gerade sagen zu gering, zu hoch
ist.
Und was ich jetzt gemacht habe ist folgendes.
Ich habe jetzt den
letzten Five Head Move gemacht, der mir
noch eingefallen ist.
Bevor ich gesagt hätte, ey, lass uns beim
Saturn ein paar SSDs kaufen und ein Intel NUC
oder sowas.
Wobei das natürlich bei uns so
sicherheitstechnisch, da hätten sie Anfälle gekriegt,
wenn ich gesagt hätte, lass uns ein Intel NUC
unter den Tisch stellen und beim Saturn ein paar
SSDs kaufen. Das hätten sie garantiert nicht
erlaubt, aber ne. Also was ich mir jetzt
überlegt habe ist folgendes.
Wir wollen einen Polygon Node betreiben.
Einen kompletten Polygon Node.
Das heißt wir brauchen mindestens
9,5 Terabyte. Aktuell
vollgesynkte Polygon Blockchain
ist 9,5 Terabyte.
Und
also sagen wir mal
wir sollten eher was Richtung
12, 15 Terabyte haben.
Weil das
wächst ja auch zunehmend.
So und jetzt kommt Five Head
Move von mir. Bei Google
habe ich eine VM angelegt
und habe das dran gehängt, was ich euch eben
gezeigt habe. Ich habe eine
VM angelegt, glaube ich,
128 GB, 32
Kerne und 9 Terabyte
Local Storage SSD.
Dann bin ich hergegangen,
habe ZFS drauf gemacht.
Ich habe euch doch gesagt,
wir brauchen mindestens 9,5 Terabyte,
besser 12. Was meint
ihr denn, inwieweit,
warum komme ich mit ZFS und 9
Terabyte hin? Was könnte
das sein? Vielleicht
denkt der eine oder andere schon dran.
Warum Polygon, warum nicht Polygon?
Eins von vielen.
In dem Fall ist es jetzt halt, wo
wir rumprobieren mit Polygon. RAM Caching.
Auch, auch, ja.
Nein,
die richtige Antwort ist Kompression.
Nein, Deed Application nicht.
Das ist zu heftig.
Das ist auch ein Punkt.
Nein, Komprimierung.
Denn, wieder erwartend,
fragt mich bitte nicht, warum.
Ich hätte selbst damit nicht gerechnet.
Ja,
wir schon.
Die wollen das.
Warum auch immer. So genau habe ich es auch nicht
gecheckt. Die wollen wirklich
komplett, also
das komplette Blockchain Archiv
von Anfang bis jetzt haben.
Und das sind aktuell 9,5 Terabyte
das Polygon Mainnet.
So.
Was habe ich gemacht? Ich habe mal getestet,
wie gut lässt sich das Ganze
komprimieren.
Und habe festgestellt,
dieses ganze Blockchain Zeug.
Warum? Ich verstehe nicht, warum.
Ich dachte eigentlich, das ist zum größten Teil random Daten,
die sich nicht gut komprimieren lassen.
Aber, es lässt sich wunderbar komprimieren.
Es lässt sich um das
mindestens um das 2,5
fache komprimieren.
Das heißt, wir können aus 9 Terabyte
können wir mal mindestens
18 Terabyte machen.
Eher 20 Terabyte.
Das ist halt mega nice.
ZF, ich glaube, beide mittlerweile.
Also BTFS hat
neuerdings ZSTD.
ZFS hat LZ4.
Mit LZ4 komprimiere ich das.
ZFS hat LZ4,
was für sowas wunderbar ist, weil LZ4
das aber so
performancemäßig
angenehmste Kompressionsverfahren
ist.
Was allerdings jetzt nicht die super
tollen Kompressionsraten,
besitzt, aber
immerhin noch reicht das ganze Blockchain Zeug
um den Faktor 2,5 zu komprimieren.
Doch, ich hab
128 Gig RAM. Also aktuell
sieht meine RAM Auslastung auf dem Server
ungefähr so aus. Wenn ich Free
eingebe,
auf meiner Kiste
steht also nicht, also
exemplarisch jetzt bei mir lokal auf meinem Server,
steht hier vorne 128 Gig
und
used
weiß ich jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht,
aber free steht zumindest irgendwie
640 MB noch da.
Also ZFS
ZFS schnappt sich
erstmal 50% des RAMs
für ZFS Dinge
und die restlichen
64 Gig
schnappt sich das ganze Blockchain Zeug
zum Sinken.
Und das brummt auf der Kiste.
Das flutscht
richtig. Das hat permanent
ungefähr sequenziell
zumindest wenn man mit Hardtop guckt,
also wenn ich auf
der Serverkiste mit Hardtop gucke,
haben wir hier konstant, also bei mir
passiert hier jetzt einfach nichts lokal in der
VM.
Wir haben konstant 500 MB
was da sequenziell
ich vermute mal, dass es eine
Mischung aus Lesen, Schreiben
ist. Ich hab's nicht so genau anguckt.
500 MB permanent
was da durch die Platte rattert.
Über 3 Prozesse aufgesplittet.
Irgendwie 200, 200,
100 und so. Das flutscht
richtig da drauf.
Also RAM ist voll, RAM ist voll.
Dafür muss man echt sagen
und jetzt mal so zum Vergleich
zum Vergleich. Ich hab euch ja gesagt
die Disks von Google sind viel zu langsam.
Nur mal so zum Vergleich
was das ausmacht bei einer
Latenzkritischen Anwendung.
Also bei Google war das
so, es hat
fast 14 Tage gebraucht
bis der initiale Sync
fertig war.
Und nicht komplett Sync, sondern nur Sync
vom letzten Snapshot. 14 Tage
ungefähr braucht das
bis das gesynct ist.
Und danach
braucht es nochmal 14 Tage
bis es das was es hinten dran ist
nach den 14 Tagen wieder aufgeholt hat.
Also du brauchst ungefähr
einen Monat
um deinen Polygon Node
zu syncen.
Und das liegt daran und wir bleiben auch nicht
komplett in Sync, weil
im Durchschnitt produziert
Polygon ungefähr 4 Blöcke pro Sekunde
und unsere
crappy Latency
VMs
schaffen zwischen
2 und 5 Blöcken die Sekunde.
Was bedeutet
wir sind eigentlich nie aktuell.
Wir sind immer hinten dran.
Und es liegt einzig und allein
daran, dass die Latenz
der Netzwerkplatten zu hoch ist.
Weil jetzt habe ich das
laufen auf meinem ZFS
erstens haben wir massig Run Cache, keine Frage.
Aber
mit ZFS bin ich 3 mal
so schnell, trotz
Filesystemkomprimierung.
Ohne Filesystemkomprimierung wäre ich
wahrscheinlich 4-5 mal so schnell.
Also während man ungefähr
mit diesen Billig Latency Platten
von Google Netzwerkplatten
ungefähr 50
ähm ja
wie erklär ich euch?
Es sind nicht Blöcke, ich sag's euch gleich.
Aber ich sag jetzt mal 50 Blöcke, weil
niemand sonst weiß wovon ich rede.
50 Blöcke pro Sekunde schafft
schafft man mit der ZFS
Kiste und Local SSDs 150
Blöcke die Sekunde.
Das ist halt schon sehr nice.
Also ZFS
hat es mal wieder geregelt.
Ja, das da.
Genau.
Das ist halt sehr zackig.
Und ich muss mal am Montag
werde ich mal gucken ob der fertig gesynct hat.
Ich vermute, dass er fertig gesynct hat.
Ich hab heute Morgen mal geguckt
wie weit das Sync ist und er hat jetzt schon
20 Tage aufgeholt.
Also sind nur noch 9 Tage hinten dran.
Und das innerhalb von
eineinhalb Tagen.
Also müsste
gehen. So Leute.
Und wer sich jetzt vielleicht fragt
was macht der Max hier überhaupt?
Und warum ist der Titel von diesem Stream so merkwürdig?
Was ich komisch finde, dass mich das noch keiner
gefragt hat, aber weil das was wir jetzt
bis jetzt gemacht haben im Stream
hat ja überhaupt nichts damit zu tun was im Titel steht.
Das kann ich euch jetzt zeigen.
Was kann man gegen
Latenzen machen? Upgraden? Wie kann man
keine Netzwerk Disks
verwenden?
Wie habt ihr denn eure DB laufen?
Also wenn ihr eure DB managed laufen
habt bei Azure, dann sollte das nach Möglichkeiten
ganz gut funktionieren.
Wenn ihr Disk
also Storage Latenzen
habt, dann könnt ihr mit den normalen Netzwerk
Platten nichts machen. Die haben halt einfach mal
ein paar Millisekunden.
Wie gesagt bei mir lokal
150 Mikrosekunden
bei Google 7-8 Millisekunden
Storage IO.
Die Latenz zwischen Datenbank und Cluster
klingt aber eher nicht nach Storage Latency
sondern nach
anderem Kram.
Bei Azure weiß ich es nicht genau.
Bei Google kannst du auswählen
kostet natürlich extra.
wie priorisiert und
ich habe vergessen wie das heißt
wo es gehandelt wird.
Du kannst bei Google irgendwie auswählen
Standard und Premium Traffic
keine Ahnung wie das
Bei Azure gibt es das bestimmt auch
ich weiß aber nicht wie es da heißt.
DB ist managed, ja dann würde ich
sagen kriegen die es schon ganz gut gebacken.
Aber wenn ihr zwischen
ihr kämpft mit
Latenzen zwischen dem Cluster und der Datenbank
ich meine der Cluster und die
Datenbank die laufen beide in Azure
nach Möglichkeit in der
gleichen, ich habe vergessen
wie es bei Azure heißt, ich mache zu viel Google in letzter Zeit.
Was ist denn das Gegenteil von
Zone und Region bei Azure?
Ähm
Zone heißt da glaube ich auch
ist schon wieder ein halbes Jahr her
oder dreiviertel Jahr her wo ich zuletzt
viel Azure gemacht habe.
Geo, Zone
und wie heißt das bei Azure?
Die haben Geo Redundant
Zone Redundant und
Rack Redundant oder so komisches Zeug.
Aber das läuft ja bei euch
eben mehr oder weniger im gleichen Standort.
Da sollte es doch keine großen Latenzen geben.
Also ich persönlich würde ja vermuten, dass
zwischen eurer Datenbank und dem Kubernetes Cluster
eigentlich unter
einer Millisekunde sein soll, aber auf jeden
Fall im einstelligen Millisekundenbereich.
Und wenn es das nicht ist,
dann suckt es extrem.
Kann man das Ganze nicht in einer Ramdisk
machen? Naja RAM gibt es
viel, also wenn du 15 Terabyte
hast, dann kannst
du das machen, ja.
Ramdisk hat aber das Problem,
dass es kein Reboot überlebt. Aber
15 Terabyte Ramdisk wird
ganz schön teuer.
Okay, da hört es bei mir auf, keine Ahnung.
Also ich weiß, Cosmos DB ist die NoSQL Geschichte von Microsoft.
Habe ich aber in der Kombi
noch nie benutzt. Kein Plasenschimmer.
So, aber
kommen wir mal zu der eigentlichen Sache, was ich heute machen wollte.
Und zwar, ihr habt
euch ja wahrscheinlich schon gefragt, warum das Streamtitel
und das, was ich mache, überhaupt nichts miteinander zu tun hat.
Das liegt daran, weil ich
wieder tausend Sachen gemacht habe, bloß nicht
das, was ich machen wollte.
Und zwar, was ich heute machen wollte,
ich wollte meine Garmin
Fahrradcomputer App weiterprogrammieren.
Und ich zeige euch mal, wie die mittlerweile aussieht, weil
mittlerweile ist die auch auf Github
und ich habe
vieles, viel dran geändert
im Vergleich zu dem, wo ihr das letzte
Mal was gesehen habt. Ich zeige euch mal,
wie das Lokal bei mir aktuell aussieht.
Downloads.
Downloads. Garmin
POG.
Ach du Scheiße, Alter, meine Projektebenahmung
ist auch wieder exzellent.
Was ist denn das Richtige hiervon, Mann?
Äh...
PyFat?
Projects?
Oder ist es
Projects 2?
Nein, es ist Projects PyFat. Ich glaube, hier ist richtig, ja?
So.
Ich zeige euch mal, wie meine App
aussah, als wir zuletzt im Stream
damit gebastelt haben. Und dann zeige ich
euch, wie sie jetzt aussieht.
Äh... Build Current Project...
Run? Nee. Äh...
Wir werden uns mit der alten App auch gar nicht
mehr aufhalten. So. Jetzt startet der
Garmin-Emulator.
Der sieht so aus, wie dieses Gerät von
Garmin halt aussieht.
Jetzt gehen wir auf Data...
Ach, fuck, Alter. Oh, hier.
Activity Data...
Start.
So. So sieht das aktuell aus.
Super billig.
Also richtig
PPGA-mäßig sieht das aus.
Und jetzt passt mal auf...
Ah. Ah, sieht richtig aus.
Richtig billig und fail irgendwie aus,
was ich hier lokal gebaut habe.
Ich habe das alles jetzt ein bisschen erweitert.
Und zwar... Guckt mal, wie
das jetzt aussieht.
Äh... Data Champ Garmin.
So sieht das jetzt aus. Also die
Karte ist drüber gepainted.
Aber die eigentliche Anzeige
sieht jetzt so aus. Schon mal deutlich
schicker.
Und kann auch schon deutlich mehr.
Und ich dachte mir, nachdem ich da letztens...
Letzten Samstag habe ich das gemacht, oder?
Ja, so letzten Samst...
Sonntag, Samstag rum.
Habe ich das... Ich kann das Ganze auch mal
auf Github pushen.
Jetzt zeige ich euch, wie das aussieht.
Da werdet ihr sehen, deutlich...
...advanceder schon. Und da wollte
ich heute mit euch ein bisschen weiter dran bauen.
Weil es fehlen noch ein paar Sachen
und vielleicht hat ja auch der ein oder andere Ideen,
wie man das noch ein bisschen verbessern kann.
Also lauffähig ist das Ganze
auf Garmin Uhren und auf Garmin
Fahrradcomputern.
Wobei es so richtig sinnvoll ist.
Eigentlich ist es eben für Fahrradcomputer gedacht.
Da steht sogar da, dass es nicht
gepflegt wird.
Ich habe nicht vor,
das auf lange Sicht zu pflegen. Ich werde das
so bauen, dass es exakt das macht,
was ich haben will. Und danach...
Ich werde das auch nicht...
Wahrscheinlich nicht im Connect Store veröffentlichen.
Schade, dass es kein C++ Projekt ist.
Oh ja, sagt ganz schlimm.
Da bin ich auch sehr traurig, dass es kein
C++ Projekt ist.
Ja, Monkey C
ist die Programmiersprache, die Garmin
möchte, dass man verwendet.
Weil Garmin der Meinung ist,
wir brauchen was eigenes dafür.
Ich meine, sie hätten JavaScript nehmen können,
sie hätten Python nehmen können, sie hätten
irgendwas Low-Level-mäßiges nehmen, aber
nein, sie nehmen Monkey C.
Was irgendwie auf Java-Basis und dann in Binary
kompiliert. Warum?
Man weiß es nicht. Garmin-Logik.
So.
Ich mache das hier mal zu.
Und jetzt öffnen wir
das...
Ja, wir trusten.
Ich weiß, dass ich Docker installiert habe.
Stellt ihr vor.
So, und jetzt zeige ich euch mal, wie das
bei mir aussieht. Build-Project.
Jawoll.
Und jetzt run.
Und ihr werdet feststellen,
es sieht
deutlich besser aus.
Gibt es neue Paper-Hintergrund-Bilder?
Ne, das gibt es schon recht lang.
So, und ihr werdet feststellen,
das sieht deutlich besser aus jetzt.
Vor allem, wenn man das
auf...
Top 5 muss man es machen, oder?
Ja.
Das sieht schon deutlich besser aus.
Und damit es noch realistischer aussieht,
muss ich mal kurz eine
Karte
da drüber overlayen.
Ja, perfekte Karte.
Ja, toll. Das will ich.
Overlayen hier. Top.
Oder?
Das da.
Das wird jetzt overlaid.
Das ist das Top hier.
Ganz toll, das brauchen wir jetzt.
Safe-Image.
BMP. Ja, super.
Display.
Wie, habe ich kein Image?
Image-Magic drauf.
Was ist mit mir los?
Normalerweise immer Image-Magic drauf.
Display 2.
Ne, wie hieß das?
Oh, bam. Perfekt.
So.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, dass es
halbwegs gescheit aussieht.
Jawoll.
Oh.
Sieht wie echt
aus, Leute. Wie echt.
Es sieht so aus, als könnte das so aussehen.
In echt, ja.
Nein, gibt es nicht.
Wundert mich. Es wundert mich extrem,
dass es das nicht gibt.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran,
dass du, dass kein C-Compiler
für diese Garmin-Sachen gibt.
Wundert mich aber echt, dass noch keiner
gebaut hat. Übrigens, die Anzeige
hier unten ist halt komplett, komplett sinnlos,
dass die da angezeigt wird. Ihr seht hier übrigens auch,
also, hier sieht man auch schön
den eigentlichen Grund, warum ich sowas gebaut habe.
Seht ihr, bei Garmin selbst
kannst du bloß zwei Felder hier unter der Map
anzeigen lassen. Und mit
meinem Data-Field kannst du drei
Felder anzeigen lassen und
noch viel besser, ihr seht,
alle drei Sekunden wechselt
das. Seht ihr?
Hier zeigt der Watt an, hier zeigt
der, Moment, warum zeigt der überhaupt?
So, besser.
Guck mal, also es
funktioniert schon relativ gut.
Der zeigt euch
den Puls, die Pulsfrequenz an,
der zeigt die
Watt, die man tritt an, wie schnell man
fährt und hier wechselt er zwischen,
zwischen, also man kann die Felder
auswählen und sie wechseln alle drei Sekunden,
wenn man mehr als eine Sache.
Okay, Chat.
Ich muss,
ich habe eigentlich gedacht,
es haben genug Leute
subscribed heute, dass das
eindeutig ist, warum das
so ist, weil das hier ein Bild ist,
wo eine Watt-Anzeige drauf ist.
Okay, ich brauche ein anderes
Bild, das verwirrt die Leute, alles klar.
Ich brauche ein anderes Bild, wo keine
Watt-Anzeige drauf ist.
Ja, top.
Ey Leute, wir machen das anders, passt mal
auf, passt mal auf. Ach so,
du meinst, warum die Watt-Anzeige hier unten doppelt
ist? Einfach aus, einfach
zu Testzwecken. Das macht überhaupt
keinen Sinn, dass die Watt-Anzeige doppelt
ist. Das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Ja, ja, da hast du schon recht, das macht überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Passt mal auf. Paint.
Zack. Schneiden das jetzt aus.
Okay, so.
Ohne, ohne
die Anzeige hier unten dran.
Und jetzt, oh, wie
paste ich das jetzt unter Linux?
Moment.
Xclip paste image.
Wie geht das?
How to copy image to clipboard to
How to copy an image?
Linux save
clipboard image.
Wie funzt denn das?
Copy image from clipboard
to file. Okay, was?
Xclip. Moment, was?
Xclip.
Jetzt wird es aber super advanced.
Selection clipboard
minus t
targets minus o
Ach, als was
ich das speichern kann. Okay,
und jetzt?
Xclip selection
clipboard minus
t image
png
minus
o nach plupp
.png. Und das hat jetzt
funktioniert?
Da habe ich meine Zweifel. Gucken wir mal.
Image cut plupp
Das hat funktioniert.
Es ist einfach da.
Image aus dem Clipboard gesaved mit
command line.
Richtig, richtig advanceder Kram hier.
So, und jetzt
kopieren wir das hier rüber.
Machen das so hin.
Ah, top.
Jetzt verwirrt es hoffentlich
keinen mehr.
Excellent, oder?
Schon mit
GT Dings.
Ist das das, was du in GTA 5 fandest?
Mit deinem Heimtrainer?
Ne, ne, das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Servus, will
Pi Hall plus Home Assistant plus
InfluxDB betreiben.
Warum eigentlich InfluxDB?
Lieber Pi 4B 8 GB
SSD oder jetzt lieber ein Pi 5?
Ich denke mal, dass die sich
verbrauchtechnisch beide
nicht sonderlich viel nehmen werden.
Unter den Voraussetzungen, dass du die
zum größten Teil eh
nicht Volllast hast oder die vor sich
hin rumeideln.
Also der Raspberry Pi mit
einer SSD ist eine ganz gute Basis
für Home Assistant.
Pi Hall kannst du da auch drauf hauen und sonst was.
Die Sache ist halt die,
wenn du Home Assistant laufen lassen willst
auf dem Raspberry Pi, dann musst du das
direkt auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen lassen
und dann bist du halt ein bisschen drauf
angewiesen, was es dort schon für Addons gibt.
Nö, brauchst du nicht.
Home Assistant speichert jetzt
standardmäßig eine SQLite Datenbank
auf der SSD, das ist voll und ganz ausbreitend.
Brauchst kein InfluxDB. Kann nicht
den Home Assistant auf einem 1 Euro
IONOS VPS. Das kannst du
theoretisch machen.
Ich glaube, dass die 1 Euro
Kiste ein bisschen wenig RAM hat.
Ich glaube, die hat bloß 256 MB RAM.
Ich glaube, das reicht nicht.
Kannst du machen. Ist halt die Frage, was
das dir bringt. Du kommst ja von dort nirgendswo dran
bei dir daheim.
Ja, aber ob Pi 4 oder 5.
Ich würde sagen, für den Anwendungszweck wird's
nicht allzu viel Unterschied machen.
Vielleicht wartest du, bis der Pi 5 raus ist,
um dir dann Pi 4 zu kaufen. Dann ist
er ein bisschen billiger.
Aber wohlgemerkt, je nachdem, was du mit der
Kiste alles machen möchtest
später, ist ein Raspberry Pi eventuell
auch gar nicht was Gutes. Also
möchtest du das irgendwann mal vielleicht als Netzwerkspeicher
verwenden, dann kannst du es vergessen mit
einem Raspberry Pi 4. Mit einem
5er vielleicht schon ein bisschen eher, aber Raspberry Pi
sind allgemein keine guten
Netzwerk-Storages.
Echt? Ja, dann kannst du... Ja, aber mit
einem Gigabyte wird's auch knapp.
Aber ansonsten wird sich
das nicht viel nehmen. Stimmt, sind die
eigentlich lieferbar?
Was ist da wupplos
zu Unraid? Ich hab nen Unraid daheim.
So richtig glücklich bin ich damit nicht.
Aber im Vergleich zu den anderen Sachen
taugt es noch ganz gut.
Also,
für nen Heimbereich ist Unraid schon in Ordnung.
Das läuft
auch schön aus dem RAM von nem USB-Stick
gebootet. Also es ist für
nen Heimbereich... Ey, so richtig glücklich bin ich damit
nicht, aber es ist das Beste,
was ich bisher gefunden hab.
Was sagt der eigentlich
Harry Base zum Raspberry
Pi 5? Die Dinger sind
echt teuer. Hoppity
hopp. Boards.
Kann man hier nicht auswählen, dass man
dass man nen Raspberry Pi 5
haben will? Ja, 5.
Not available.
Alter.
Kann man fast denken, ich rauche, man.
Ich rauche aber nicht.
Boah, voll verschluckt an
mir selbst, irgendwie.
Ja, der Raspberry Pi 4 braucht schon
unter Volllast
mindestens das... Die sagen, du sollst das
offizielle 5,1
Volt 3 Ampere Netzteil
benutzen. Es geht aber
auch mit vielen anderen Sachen. Und beim Raspberry Pi
5 wird's ähnlich sein.
Wobei der halt dann tatsächlich echt wohl
Probleme bekommt. Aber
Raspberry Pis kacken ja in der Regel nicht ab,
sondern tacken sich dann runter.
Das geht schon.
Hm. Ach ja.
Zum Thema Husten.
Ich hab euch doch letztens erzählt, mein Vater war
im Krankenhaus. Der hatte nen Herzinfarkt.
Sein zweiter schon.
Und
da war ich letztens bei ihm.
Ich hab ihm seinen Drucker angeschlossen.
Und ratet mal, was das erste
war, was ich gesehen hab.
Was er gemacht hat.
Ich mein, es ist jetzt nicht schwer drauf zu kommen.
Weil, von der
Themenüberleitung. Ratet mal
was das erste war, was ich gesehen hab, was er gemacht hat.
Zigarette.
Korrekt.
Der hat, der hat ne Zigarette
hat direkt ne Zigarette im Mund
stecken gehabt. Geraucht.
Da hab ich auch gesagt, sag mal, meinste nicht
so nach nem Herzinfarkt
und so, wär's vielleicht
nehmen wir ganz gut jetzt nicht zu rauchen.
Und daraufhin
hat er gesagt, ach
ist doch auch egal. Sogar
sogar der Arzt hat gesagt
ähm, das machen
macht jetzt auch keinen Unterschied mehr.
Im Leben hat der Arzt
das nicht gesagt, Leute. Im Leben
nichts.
Wisst ihr, ihr seid im Krankenhaus,
ja, und
die haben euch gerade behandelt
und Herzinfarkt und alles
und der Arzt fragt sie, fragt
fragt euch dann, und äh
rauchen sie? Und du sagst, ja klar
und ich rauche jetzt auch weiter. Dann sagt
der Arzt natürlich auch garantiert da drauf,
ach kein Problem, macht eh nix.
Machen sie ruhig weiter.
Und ich hab auch gedacht, jaja,
ganz bestimmt, ganz bestimmt. Also,
laut seiner, laut seiner Aussage
bringt das nix.
Er kann ruhig weiter rauchen, ja.
Ich hab auch gedacht, naja, gut, also
irgendwie ein bisschen selber dran schultern.
Ja, und es wird, es wird noch besser.
Es wird noch besser.
Ich hab euch ja schon mal die, die, die
Painschamp-Stories erzählt.
Also mein Vater ist
jetzt glaube ich 75.
So.
Und vielleicht, vielleicht erinnert sich noch der eine
oder andere. Ich hab, ich hab euch das ja schon mal erzählt.
Ähm, aber
er hat mir letztens
erzählt, er hat jetzt wieder ne Freundin.
Und zwar
in der Karibik. Ratet
mal, Chatke,
ratet mal, wie alt
seine Freundin in der Karibik ist.
Freundin in Anführungszeichen,
ja. Also ich geh davon,
ich geh davon aus,
das ist so ne typische Geschichte.
Wir, wir, wir machen
Rentnern schöne Augen,
damit wir, damit wir ein bisschen Geld
abgreifen können. Aber hey, ich denke,
solange sich beide Seiten darauf,
der, der Sache bewusst sind,
dann, ja, dann
soll's halt so sein, ne.
26, ja.
26.
Und, und
...
Ich weiß ja nicht, also,
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass der wirklich
denkt, dass
die was von ihm will, weil sie
ihn so toll findet, sondern einfach, weil
er da ein bisschen Kohle überweist.
Aber,
Alter, oh, der macht so viel Probleme
die ganze Zeit mit irgendwas.
Und, und sich selbst
vor allem. Kann er nicht irgendwas
normales machen für sein Alter? Modelleisenbahn
bauen oder,
oder am Fenster
stehen und, und
irgendwelche Leute
anscheißen, die, die schräg parken
oder sowas. Was, was Opas halt
so machen normalerweise, ja.
Aber nee, geht nicht.
Geht nicht. Der muss so
Zeug machen, ja.
Und sie haben ihn ja auch
schon beschissen. Sie haben ihn ja auch
schon beschissen. Er war ja dort im Urlaub.
Ich will nicht wissen, was sie da getrieben haben.
Er war ja da wohl irgendwie auch im Urlaub.
Und als er vom Urlaub wiederkam,
als er vom Urlaub wiederkam,
äh, gab es
zufälligerweise,
ganz zufälligerweise,
ähm, Abbuchungen
von seinem Konto.
Unberechtigte Abbuchungen von
seinem Konto.
Wo die wohl herkommen können? Hm.
Es kann nicht sein,
dass ihn da jemand beschissen hat oder so.
Nein.
Da geht doch dein komplettes Erbe drauf. Also wenn ich
von einem nix erbe, dann ist es mein Vater.
Der Kerl hat so viel Probleme
und, und
der hat, der hat auch schon
eine Privatinsolvenz gemacht und hat jetzt schon
wieder Schulden. Ich bin mit
dem ja nicht so dicke, ja. Ich hab mit meinem Vater
jahrelang nix zu tun, jahrzehntelang nix großartig
zu tun gehabt. Und eigentlich hab ich mit meinem Vater
jetzt auch nix großartig zu tun.
Außer, dass er mich ab und zu
anpumpt, was Geld angeht.
Und, ähm,
ja, mich fragt,
wenn, wenn bei ihm die Technik nicht
geht. Ich versuch so weit wie möglich zu ihm
zu ignorieren, weil ich find's irgendwie ein bisschen,
ich weiß nicht, ich, ich, ja, ich hatte
über 20 Jahre mit dem nix, ach, länger.
Ja.
Locker. 25 Jahre.
Mit dem nix großartig zu tun.
Ja.
Nicht geredet, nix gemacht und so.
Ich hab da keine großartige Beziehung zu dem.
Und,
also zumindest erben werd ich,
erben werd ich von dem garantiert nix.
100% werd ich nichts erben.
Da gibt's nix.
So. Aber, jetzt kommt,
jetzt kommt ja der neue Hammer.
Was ich euch eigentlich erzählen wollte. So.
Ja, 26
jährige Freundin in der Karibik,
wora, wisst ihr,
und eines der Dinge halt, die mich immer
extrem aufregt ist,
dass der permanent sich
irgendeinen Blödsinn
an den Haaren herbeizieht,
äh, ausdenkt,
sich zusammenschwindelt,
um einen dazu
zu bringen, Sachen zu machen, die man will.
Ja. Zum Beispiel,
als er sich da, die haben ihm das Konto
gesperrt, darauf, weil es, äh,
weil es unberechtigte Abbuchungen
gegeben hat. Und daraufhin hat er
ein Problem, weil er hat natürlich jegliches Bargeld schon mal
wieder ausgegeben, was er hatte.
Und, und daraufhin hat er übelst
Panik bei mir geschoben, äh,
wie kannst du deinen Vater verhungern lassen,
und sowas. Ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, Alter,
der ruft mich an, erzählt mir so Zeug,
wie kannst du deinen Vater verhungern lassen.
Alter, ich hab mit dir 25 Jahre nix zu tun
gehabt, großartig.
Ja.
Und, als ich ihm dann gesagt hab,
also, ganz ehrlich,
wir haben nie großartig was miteinander zu tun
gehabt, ja. Und das einzige, was ich
dann immer höre, ist, wenn du irgendwie, irgendwie
Kohle brauchst, oder wenn irgendwas ist,
okay, ich will nicht, dass du
verhungerst, meinetwegen, komm,
ich, ich bring dir, ich bring,
ich bring dir, ich bring dir mal 50 Euro
vorbei. Bin ich da, bin ich da über
ne Stunde hingefahren,
da hab ich
55 Euro vorbeigebracht,
Nudel mit Lachs hätte ich, glaub ich, der Nudel mit Lachs
hin, hin, hin,
hinbringen sollen, äh.
Naja, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Jetzt hab ich's, hab ich's vergessen, ähm.
Ja, ich hab ja auch gesagt, du wirst
schon nicht verhungern.
50 Euro.
Jetzt hab ich, jetzt hab ich vergessen, worauf ich eigentlich drauf
raus, drauf raus wollte.
Ja, genau, jetzt weiß ich's wieder. So.
Und,
ich hab ihm erst gesagt, wir hatten 25 Jahre,
25 Jahre,
äh, nix miteinander zu tun, so,
und jetzt, eigentlich, eigentlich will ich
auch nicht großartig, und,
äh, ich, ich wollt eigentlich nur meine Ruhe.
Ja, zumindest, zumindest
hat er dann gemerkt, dass er bei mir nicht weiterkommt
und ich ihm kein Geld gebe. So.
Ich bin dann, ich bin dann doch hingefahren, hab ihm 50 Euro
gebracht, aber, ähm,
okay, der hat, der hat gemerkt, dass
er nicht weit, weiterkommt, so jetzt,
dass er, dass er keine Kohle kriegt.
Und dann hat er auf einmal erzählt,
seine Freundin in der
Karibik wäre schwanger,
und das
Kind, oder, oder, oder
war schwanger, oder so,
und wenn er denen jetzt kein Geld schickt,
dann verhungert das Kind.
Das ist kein Witz!
Das hat er mir sinngemäß so
erzählt. Der hat sich, der hat sich
random Geschichten ausgedacht,
dass ich mich so unter Druck gesetzt
fühle, dass ich ihm Geld überweise.
Ihr, ihr, Leute,
jetzt mal seriously, Hand aufs Herz, ja, ihr hattet wahrscheinlich
alle ein bisschen bessere, habt wahrscheinlich
besseres Verhältnis, bessere Beziehung zu eurem Vater.
Ihr könnt euch das wahrscheinlich nicht vorstellen,
wie das so, ne, wie das
wie das ist.
Aber das ist, das ist, er ist ein sehr weird Champ,
kann ich euch sagen.
Das ist, das ist, das ist sehr weird Champ.
Scammer. Na, Moment, Scammer,
ein Scammer ist mein Vater wirklich,
gar nicht in Bezug auf,
auf diese Sache mit dem,
mit den 50 Euro.
Der hat ja, der war
ja fast im Knast mal,
wegen, wegen Betrug,
ja, also er hat wirklich Leute gescampt früher.
Ich sag fast, weil er war nicht
im Knast, aber fast im Knast gelandet.
Wegen Betrug damals. Der hatte,
habe ich euch glaube ich schon mal erzählt,
der hatte
in der, ähm,
in der, also vor
Internet, lange vor Internet,
also das war dann wahrscheinlich so
1990 oder so rum,
hatte der eine Partnervermittlung
für, so in Hessen.
Und
der hat die Leute halt übelst gescampt dort.
Der hat die Leute gescampt.
Und jetzt, ich erzähl euch mal, wie er die Leute gescampt hat.
Und zwar, was übrigens,
was übrigens, worauf freigesprochen wurde.
Das, das war kein Betrug.
Also, passt mal auf. Der hat,
ähm,
seine, seine, ja,
die Klientinnen,
die dort halt sich angemeldet haben,
bei der Partnervermittlung.
Die muss natürlich ordentlich Mitgliederbeitrag bezahlen.
Und dementsprechend haben die natürlich
auch erwartet, dass,
dass, ja, da
nette Herren vermittelt werden.
Und was hat er gemacht?
Mein Vater hatte so nen, so nen Pool,
würd ich mal sagen, aus fünf, sechs,
ähm, sehr,
sagen wir mal, äh, optisch
ansprechenden
Herren am Start.
Wahrscheinlich auch ne ganze Ecke jünger als die Omas
oder so, die sich da, die sich da angemeldet
haben. Und er hat dann
einfach die, aus diesem
Pool von den fünf Leuten, allen
Omas die heimgeschickt,
als, wir haben hier jemanden für sie gefunden.
Und die sind dann halt heimgefahren
zu den Omas und haben denen dann
da schöne Augen gemacht und haben
ihnen erzählt, äh, wie toll sie sind
und, und die Omas waren halt alle total
verzückt und haben, haben richtig
krass Mitgliedsbeitrag reingebuttert.
In diese Partnervermittlung.
Ja. Und zumindest, die wollten
ihn ja verklagen, dann am Ende, als
das alles rausgekommen ist.
Aber, der wurde freigesprochen,
weil,
der Vertrag,
da stand das drinne.
Also in dem Vertrag, was die Leute
geschrieben haben, stand das mehr oder
weniger sinngemäß drinne, dass es,
dass hier nichts vermittelt wird oder sonst was
und keine Garantie auf irgendwas besteht und
es muss wohl so gewesen sein,
dass sogar der Richter, äh, während der
Verhandlung, ich sag jetzt mal
Frau Müller, ich hab keine Ahnung wie die hieß,
ja, die, die dort gesessen hat,
der Richter muss sogar die Frau Müller während der Verhandlung
gefragt haben, sagen sie mal, wie
kann man sowas unterschreiben?
Also, das war wirklich,
da wurde, da wurde, der hat wirklich viel
gescampt in seinem Leben, die Leute, ja.
Aber er wurde freigesprochen am Ende.
Das ist, das ist
der Rentner-Trick, bevor es den Rentner-Trick gab.
Also, ganz
im Ernst, der hat wirklich viele Leute gescampt.
Zumindest bisher,
bisher, ne, also
Verwandtschaft hat er eigentlich nie gescampt.
Das war kein Scam, korrekt.
Du hast das, du hast das richtig erkannt.
Rein rechtlich gesehen war
das kein Scam, sondern legit Business.
Ja, korrekt.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Man kann sich
sicherlich sagen,
dass das aber vielleicht aus moralischer
Sicht durchaus, durchaus
gescampt war,
aber aus rechtlicher Sicht nicht.
Ja, korrekt. Legit, legit Business.
Und mal ganz im Ernst, wenn du dir
heute diesen ganzen Scheiß anguckst,
wie heute die Leute verarscht werden, so viel
anders ist das nicht. Bloß, dass es im Internet
Zeitalter angekommen ist und vielleicht
halt nicht nur die Omas veräppelt werden.
Michael, fünf Spiljahren. Nein, ich spül den Sub.
Lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Also, das ist heute halt
alles der gleiche Scheiß, ja?
Halt ein bisschen anders
angepasst an die jeweilige Zeit.
Dieses Ganze kommt heute
ohne Scheiß. Wisst ihr, was mein Vater heute machen
würde, wenn er, wenn er heute in dem Alter
wäre und
der würde heute
Come in die Gruppe Scam machen. 100 pro.
Das wird einfach so gut passen
zu ihm. Come in die Gruppe wird er
machen. Der wäre einer der Ersten gewesen,
der Come in die Gruppe machen würde.
Jetzt nicht mehr, jetzt ist es ja ausgelutscht.
Aber wenn er heute, sagen wir mal nochmal
so 35, 40 wäre und das
im Internet so voller, wenn er in meinem Alter wäre,
ja? Heute. Und das mitgekriegt
hätte, der hätte ein Come in die Gruppe
Scam. Garantiert. Das wäre der Erste gewesen.
Und damit hätte er richtig Arsche
gemacht. Also, Geld
verdient hat er ohne Ende damals.
Hat natürlich auch alles wieder ausgegeben. Also,
mein Vater hat Geld, der hat massig Kohle
damals bekommen, aber halt alles
ausgegeben. Und das ist auch
eine Sache, die nehme ich ihm heute
noch übel.
Weil, der hat da, wie gesagt,
der war während seiner, während dieser Zeit
war der wirklich super
im Business drin. Kann ich gleich
was zu sagen. Super im Business
drin. Der hat, das waren noch keine
Euro, das waren noch Mark.
Der hat so viel im Monat
verdient, dass der 10.000
Euro im Monat einfach für Random
Zeug ausgeben konnte.
Und, äh, nicht Euro, Mark.
10.000 Mark im Monat
konnte der einfach mal random für, für,
just for fun ausgeben. Also, der hat
damals wirklich richtig Arsche gemacht.
So, und jetzt kommt's.
Und jetzt kommt's.
Ich war damals noch nicht alt.
Keine Ahnung, fünf, sechs
oder so.
Meine Mutter, alleinerziehend
mit mir, hat damals
äh, gearbeitet in der
Arztpraxis, hat kaum was verdient.
Und, der hat keinen Unterhalt
bezahlt. Und meine Mutter
hat dann zu ihm irgendwann mal gesagt, jetzt
hier, wie sieht's aus, bezahl halt mal Unterhalt.
Und daraufhin muss er wohl
geantwortet haben, ich kann keinen Unterhalt
bezahlen, weil, wenn
ich nicht mindestens 10.000 Euro
im Monat, 10.000 Mark im Monat für
mich habe, dann kann ich nicht, äh,
leben oder so.
War, war die Aussage von ihm damals.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen,
Alter.
Obviously. Es ist nicht,
es ist nicht möglich. Also,
Leute, ihr kennt das Problem vielleicht auch.
Unter 10.000 Euro
im Monat, kommt man nicht aus.
Oder? Es ist, es
geht einfach nicht.
Ich glaube, es ist, es geht, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das
geht überhaupt, unter 10.000 Euro im Monat.
Geht, geht
einfach nix. Das geht nicht.
Es ist nicht möglich,
unter 10.000 Euro im Monat.
Der hatte, und da bist
der Obdachlose in Frankfurt.
Der hat das richtige
mindset gehabt. Das wäre
heute so ein richtiger Lifestyle
und, und komm in die Gruppe call.
Das kann ich mir richtig gut vorstellen,
bei ihm.
Richtig, richtig gering verdient.
Gut, der hat, der hat's aber
damals, der hat's damals auch echt
zelebriert, ne? Mit drei
BMWs und allem möglichen Zeug.
Also, das muss man, da hat er schon,
der hat schon geklotzt
und nicht gekleckert damals, was Geld ausgeben
angeht. Deswegen hat er heute auch keins mehr.
Weil er alles zum Fenster rausgeschmissen
hat. Naja, also,
ich sag euch,
das, zumindest,
um das jetzt mal,
um das jetzt mal abzukürzen,
da wollte er,
wie gesagt, er wollte mir halt das Geld
aus den Rippen leiern irgendwie. Und da hat er sich
immer neue Sachen zu ausgedacht, bis,
bis irgendwie arme Kinder müssen verhungern,
wenn ich ihm kein Geld überweise und sowas. So richtig,
richtig krasses Zeug. Und das regt mich halt
am meisten, am meisten drauf,
dass der immer sich so random Zeug
ausdenkt, um einen dazu
zu bringen, das zu machen, was man will.
So, und, ja.
Ja, natürlich stehen die auf
ihm, weil er da Geld hinüberweist. Das ist klar.
So, aber,
jetzt, jetzt sitz ich vorm PC und
laber mit random Leuten online. Siehste?
So sieht's aus.
Aber, ich mein, das ist für mich
das Beste, was ich machen könnte.
Stellt euch mal vor, ich würde offline mit euch
reden. Da wird, das wär ja noch
schlimmer. Also für euch
und für mich. Aber das
eigentliche, worauf ich rauswollte jetzt,
ähm, also,
um diese, um diese ganze Story drumherum.
Also, wie gesagt, das erste
war, dass ich ihn nach dem Herzinfarkt
mit der, mit der Kippe im Mund in der Wohnung
sitzen hab, sehen. Und das
nächste, was er zu mir gesagt hat, so eine typische
Antwort von meinem Vater ist, das nächste, was er zu mir
gesagt hat, wo es da drum ging, so mit,
ähm, wie er versorgt
wird und sowas, hat er halt gemeint, ja,
kommt hier, es kommt jetzt regelmäßig eine Pflegerin
von der, von der Krankenkasse
und, äh,
zieht ihn irgendwie um und kümmert sich da drum
und so. Eigentlich müsste der in irgendeinem
Wohnheim oder so, aber den schmeißen
die da instant raus. Naja,
und,
zumindest, das nächste, was er dann gesagt hat,
ist, aber, das ist alles nicht so
schlimm, und ich kann
das jetzt nicht auf Twitch sagen, was er genau
gesagt hat, weil, das ist extrem
monka-tos, deswegen
werde ich das jetzt etwas verpacken
in,
ja, äh, kompatiblere Twitch-Sprache.
Dann hat er gesagt
zu mir, ey, also es ist nicht
illegal, was er gesagt hat,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall Twitch-tos, ja.
Ähm, hat er zu mir
gesagt, ja, aber ich kenne da zwei Spanierinnen,
die bestelle ich mir
jetzt, die kümmern sich dann um mich.
The fuck,
alter!
Das erste, was dir einfällt,
das erste, was dir einfällt, wenn du
aus dem Krankenhaus kommst mit einem Herzinfarkt,
dass sich irgendwie zwei Spanierinnen,
das sind doch keine Krankenpflegerinnen,
das sind, weiß ich nicht,
welche Leute das sind, aber,
oh, meine Güte, alter.
Und
da habe ich ihn auch gefragt,
meinst du nicht, die bescheißen dich?
Weil die kommen doch nicht aus reiner
Nächstenliebe da jetzt hier zu dir.
Außerdem, du hast eine Mini-Wohnung,
wie soll das hier mit drei Leuten funktionieren?
Und dann habe ich gesagt, weißt du was, eigentlich überhaupt nicht
mein Problem, wir haben hier nichts groß
miteinander zu tun und, weißt du was, mach was
du willst.
Und, und ich, ich hau,
ich hau jetzt einfach, ich hau jetzt einfach wieder ab.
Und dann hat er noch gemeint,
so, nee, nee, und jetzt wird's
jetzt wird's richtig cringe.
Hat er noch gemeint, nee, nee, ach,
die Spanierinnen, die holt er sich ja
nicht zum Pflegen, die, die dürfen
ihn dann nachts massieren.
Oh nein, ich will's nicht wissen, ich muss unbedingt
weg. Ich muss ganz schnell
weg, alter.
Oh. Naja, zumindest
ein paar Tage später,
ein paar Tage
später hat er mir eine E-Mail geschrieben,
ähm, es kommen jetzt
doch keine Spanierinnen,
sondern, äh,
das macht er doch nicht, weil dann
wird er nicht gesund, so.
Und wisst ihr warum, äh, äh,
Moment, fuck, ist,
ah, ich hab irgendwie, bin gerade über's
Kabel gerollt.
Hoffe das, ich hoffe das tut jetzt wieder.
Äh, ähm,
geht das jetzt?
Test, Test, blub, blub, blub.
Test, Test, blub, blub, blub, ja.
Ja, geht.
Ja, und wisst ihr, warum ich denke, dass sie nicht,
dass sie nicht gekommen sind?
Ich glaube nicht, dass er, also er hat mir geschrieben,
er hat die wieder abbestellt, aber ich persönlich glaube
ja, die sind einfach nicht aufgetaucht.
Weil denen auch gedämmert ist,
zu so einem, zu so einem random
Rentner nach Deutschland fahren, von Spanien
aus, in Spanien können wir auch Geld verdienen,
die paar Euro von denen brauchen wir nicht.
Ja, oder es gibt gar keine Spanierinnen,
das kann natürlich auch sein. Aber
das ist, ah, das ist so peinlich
alles, man, und, ah, kann der
nicht, ich mein, welcher Rentner
mit 75 kommt auf so Ideen?
Kann der nicht irgendwas ein bisschen weniger
ähm, ja,
äh, stressiges
machen? So irgendwas, was,
was machen Leute mit 75 denn normalerweise?
Ja, sich über, über Falschparker
aus dem Fenster aufregen,
Fernseh gucken, äh,
ganzen
Tag beim Bäcker sitzen und nur einen Kaffee
trinken, irgendwie
Rasen mähen, keine Ahnung,
das soll auch,
Eisenbahn, der, der
macht die ganze Zeit, ihr
habt ja auch irgendeinen Scheiß, man,
der in die Hose geht.
Der hat ne Privatinsolvenz
gemacht vor ein paar Jahren und
jetzt schon wieder Schulden. Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wie das
funktioniert.
Ja, doch, ich weiß wie's funktioniert, aber wie kann man das auf die Reihe kriegen?
Oh, Leute, ich
sag euch, ich sorg euch für das
super krasse Gesaytrack, aber
das ist echt nicht normal,
ohne Scheiß. Es ist wirklich,
ja, er soll Puzzle spielen und
Solitär spielen oder irgendwelche
All-Pay-to-Win-Geschichten oder irgendwas.
Letztens hat er mich wieder angerufen,
er hat sich schon wieder von seinem Konto ausgesperrt.
Was macht der denn den ganzen Tag?
Und bei ihm weißt du halt nie,
stimmt das, was er sagt?
Oder hat er sich's jetzt ausgedacht?
Oder, oh, es,
ich mein, ganz egal ist es mir
ja trotzdem irgendwo nicht.
Ah, es ist, es ist echt,
es ist super anstrengend, Leute.
Mega anstrengend, äh,
MonkaS.
Richtig, MonkaS.
Ja, mir wär's auch lieber
mit Solitär spielen.
Eigentlich, eigentlich wollte ich mich um meine,
meine, äh, Garmin-App kümmern.
Ich glaube, den Streamtitel haben wir heute genau fünf Minuten
verfolgt bis jetzt.
Ich hab noch gar nicht getestet, ob ich mit meinem Finger
überhaupt gescheit tippen kann gerade.
Es gibt übrigens was Neues
von der Versicherung, beziehungsweise von meinem
Anwalt.
Der hat jetzt an die Versicherung
geschrieben, dass, ähm,
dass es sie ungefähr
4500 Euro kosten wird und sie jetzt endlich
mal überweisen sollen.
Also, wenn ich Glück hab, hab ich bald die Kohle.
Und ich kann jetzt mal
so langsam nach dem neuen, nach dem neuen Fahrrad
gucken.
Also, ich kann mir das Fahrrad auch schon kaufen,
bevor, bevor ich das Geld hab, aber
das ist das fürs Fahrrad.
Aber ich bin mir noch gar nicht
so genau sicher, was ich mir kaufen soll.
Entweder kauf ich mir exakt das gleiche Fahrrad wieder,
also quasi das hier,
aber ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, ich hol mir ein anderes.
Was war mit dem Rad?
Ich wurde
auf dem Fahrradweg von einem Auto
umgefahren. Und jetzt ist das Fahrrad
kaputt.
Ist das alte Schrott oder lässt sich's
fixen? Ne.
Es lässt sich nicht fixen.
Mit dem Finger, ich hab mir den Finger geschnitten heute Morgen.
Ähm.
Ja,
das wird auch mal Zeit, ne.
Also, also, das alte Fahrrad
hat laut dem Gutachter noch einen Restwert
von glaube ich 60 Euro
oder sowas.
Das hat 3500 Euro gekostet.
Und das zu
reparieren ist teurer
als neues zu
kaufen. Eine ganze Ecke teurer.
Aber ist ja auch klo.
Ist ja auch klar.
Der Rahmen ist nicht ganz. Das ist ein Carbon-Rahmen,
der einiges abbekommen hat an Kratzern.
Er hat zwar keine offensichtlichen Brüche,
aber das weißt du bei Carbon ja nie.
Zumindest, was ich
jetzt gemacht hab ist,
es ist so gut wie alles im Arsch.
Also, Leute. Die Schaltung ist
verbogen. Der Sattel ist zerkratzt.
Der Lenker ist zerkratzt.
Der Rahmen ist zerkratzt.
Die Pedale sind zerkratzt.
Ähm.
Was hab ich noch vergessen?
Aber die Kette geht noch. Die Kette geht noch.
Die Kette geht noch und
ähm, die Kurbel ist auch
verkratzt. Ähm, was ist
warte mal, ich dreh mich mal kurz um.
Was? Okay.
Die Kette.
Ich glaub die Kette
ist das einzige
von dem Fahrrad, was man theoretisch noch
verwenden könnte.
Das hab ich mir auch schon angeguckt.
Bin ich auch schon mit am gucken.
Zumindest, eine
in Anführungsstrichen gute Sache hat es.
Ich hab mir
so einen Heimtrainer gekauft.
Nö, mach ich nicht.
Ich hab das Ding auch aktuell auf dem Heimtrainer stehen.
Weil auf die Straße geh ich damit
nicht mehr. Dann fällt mir das komplett noch auseinander.
Aber auf dem Heimtrainer
da ist es egal, dass die Schaltung
drei Gänge überspringt
beim Schalten.
Äh, nein, einen Wahoo Kick Rekord.
So ein Ding, wo man
das Hinterrad ausbaut und
direkt drauf macht.
Und deswegen, ich werd das Fahrrad einfach auf dem Smarttrainer
stehen lassen und damit da fahren.
Damit. Da ist es auch egal,
wenn es auseinanderfällt.
Und ob der Lenker verkratzt ist.
Und dann kauf ich mir jetzt ein neues.
Also, entweder, ich
eigentlich wollte ich Proggas-Stells machen heute.
Leute, ich vermute Proggas-Stells...
Seid ihr mir böse, wenn wir jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde schwätzen
und wir das nächste Mal Proggas-Stells machen?
Ich glaube, so wirklich viel können wir heute eh nicht mehr machen.
Weil...
Ich seh schon
Rage-Mode activated.
Fünf Uhr? Was?
Was ist um fünf Uhr?
Ach, erst fünf. Erst fünf, ja.
Aber 18 Uhr wollte ich was essen.
Und ich bin schon zwei Stunden
on.
Also, zumindest...
Ich zeig euch zumindest mal...
Leute, eins machen wir auf jeden Fall noch.
Das wenigstens die Proggas-Leute.
Ich zeig euch mal, was ich gebaut habe.
Weil das neue doch jetzt schon deutlich besser aussieht
als das alte, was ich gebaut habe.
Muss man ja schon zugeben.
Also, ich bin, um das jetzt nochmal
zwei Minuten, um das abzuschließen.
Also, entweder kauf ich mir das gleiche Fahrrad nochmal.
Wobei ich persönlich
eigentlich darauf
schiele, kein
Shimano Di2
Wie heißt denn das auf Deutsch?
Di2? Mehr zu kaufen?
Nicht, weil ich das schlecht gefunden hätte.
Ganz im Gegenteil.
Ich fand die elektronische Schaltung extremely pog.
Das dumme, was
mir überhaupt nicht gefällt ist,
dass das so ein komplett closed System ist.
Du kannst
beispielsweise, also du hast
hier oben auf dem Lenker, hast du Knöpfe.
Man sieht's nicht richtig, aber
hier neben sind Knöpfe.
Damit kann man, wenn man die mit
seinem Fahrradcomputer gepairt hat,
beispielsweise
beim Garmin die Seiten umschalten
und sowas. Sehr praktisch.
Da musst du nämlich nicht vom Lenker weggreifen
und auf deinem Fahrradcomputer rumtouchen.
Also du hast quasi im Lenker so integrierte Buttons.
Das ist cool, das funktioniert
mit dem Garmin, aber
nachdem Shimano der Meinung ist, dass es ein
komplett closed sourced
Bluetooth-Protokoll ist,
was nur auserwählte Hersteller benutzen dürfen,
ist natürlich Custom Integration
extrem doof. Also ich könnte
zum Beispiel aus so einem Garmin-Plugin
hier gar nicht auf meine
Schaltungs...
Sachen zugreifen.
Deswegen habe ich mir überlegt, ob ich mir
nicht ein SRAM...
Wie spricht man die Dinge eigentlich aus?
Sagen bei den Videos alle immer SRAM,
aber ich habe keine Ahnung, ob man die nicht
vielleicht sogar SRAM ausspricht.
Sagen alle immer SRAM.
Und SRAM ist Open, was
den Funkstandard angeht. Da kann man
theoretisch dann sogar so abgedrehtes
Zeug machen, wie die Button
die Buttons
von dem...
von der SRAM-Schaltung
kann man dann theoretisch sogar mit einem
Plugin abgreifen
und damit sein Hoftor aufmachen,
wenn man das integriert
bekommt über sein Smart Home und sowas.
Ihr kennt mich, eigentlich
prinzipiell ist es scheißegal
zum Fahrradfahren. Es macht keinen Unterschied,
ob das so eine Schaltung ist
oder so eine Schaltung. Klar, kannst du sicherlich
sagen, vielleicht in ganzen Nuancen
das eine oder das andere, aber eigentlich macht es keinen Unterschied.
Aber ihr kennt mich, ich bin ein
Fan von Basteln
und umso offener die Sachen sind,
die Funkprotokolle und Sachen, die man damit
machen kann, umso lieber ist es
mir. Das heißt, ich bin aktuell
tatsächlich am überlegen,
ob ich mir das neue Fahrrad
kaufe mit SRAM
elektronischer Schaltung.
Und eventuell, und das ist auch das Gute
bei SRAM, du kannst
deutlich mehr Komponenten miteinander
verbinden als mit Shimano. Shimano
hat da so, du musst das mit dem
und dem und dem verwenden und das funktioniert nur das
zusammen. Bei SRAM kannst du viel
mehr Komponenten miteinander mischen.
Also du kannst zum Beispiel die
Schalthebel nehmen von der
Straßen,
von dem Straßenset und
eine Mountainbike Schaltung dran machen
oder sowas. Das geht bei Shimano
nicht gescheit, das geht bei
SRAM easy, weil das alles das gleiche
Protokoll spricht und miteinander funktioniert.
Also aus
den Gesichtspunkten tendiere
ich aktuell zu
SRAM elektronischen Schaltung.
Die
die vielleicht ein
ein bisschen
mehr Übersetzung noch hat.
Weil
die vom aktuellen Rad hat
40 Zähne vorne
42 hinten.
Damit kommt man gut überall hoch.
Außer dort
wo ich letztens gefahren bin
16% hatte ich echt meine Probleme hochzukommen.
Also bei so richtig
paar hundert Meter lang super steilen
würde ich mir vielleicht wünschen,
dass es hinten vielleicht
einen 46er oder gar
einen 50er gibt.
Welchen FTP?
Das willst du nicht wissen. Mein FTP ist so
dermaßen schlecht.
Ich hab ja auch erst angefangen zu fahren.
Ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Ich müsste bei Swift mal
den Test machen.
Ich kann dir aber sagen, was ich bei Swift fahre,
wenn ich fahre.
Da fahre ich immer die 1,5 Watt
pro Kilogramm.
Kategorien.
Also das ist wirklich nicht gut.
Man sagt ja so 1,1
bis 1,5 Watt pro Kilogramm
ist quasi
ein Anfänger.
Und ab 2,5 bist du dann
fortgeschrittener und da drüber wird es dann richtig extrem.
Nur mal zum Vergleich.
Dass ihr wisst, wie schlecht ich bin.
Bei der Tour de France
fahren die Leute teilweise
den Berg mit 6,8 Watt das Kilogramm
Körpergewicht hoch.
Die wiegen auch nur die Hälfte von mir
und machen ihr ganzes Leben nichts anderes.
Aber ich
FTP ist
die Wattanzahl, die du treten kannst
über
25 Minuten?
Eine Stunde?
Eine Stunde, ja okay.
Stunde, genau.
Also die Leistung, die du bringen kannst über eine Stunde.
Und ich weiß
es nicht genau,
was ich hab, aber
es ist schlecht.
Also wenn ich
bei Swift
Also ich kann bei Swift dauerhaft
zu 130, 140 Watt
fahren.
Alles mehr halte ich die Zeit
nicht durch.
Aber es ist Übungssache.
Nachdem ich noch nicht so lange Fahrrad fahre wieder.
Ich bin zuversichtlich,
dass es besser wird.
Beim Rennen wurde es ja auch relativ schnell besser.
Nach 2 Monaten Rennen bin ich
von...
Bin ich von
ähm
über 8 Minuten 30 pro
Kilometer runter
jetzt auf
ich glaube
5 Minuten 30
pro Kilometer, über 5 Kilometer.
Meine normale Strecke
ist ungefähr immer 6,2 Kilometer.
Und ich denke,
dass das beim Fahrradfahren auch
gerade am Anfang schnell besser wird.
Wenn ich es regelmäßig mache.
Und es ist mir auch ganz gut,
dass ich jetzt diesen Smart Trainer hier daheim habe.
Mit dem Fahrrad drauf.
Da kann ich nämlich einfach jeden Tag
oder jeden zweiten Tag mal so 45 Minuten, Stunde fahren.
Und das bringt halt richtig was.
Gerade um
so die Beinmuskeln
ein bisschen da
dran zu gewöhnen.
Ah, es geht.
Also ich hätte selbst nicht gedacht,
dass mir das mal so viel Spaß macht.
So, aber
damit zumindest der Streamtitel irgendwie noch
was mit der Realität zu tun hat, was wir heute machen.
Also, ich habe euch die App
gezeigt, die ich für meinen Garmin
programmiert habe.
Beziehungsweise, es ist keine App.
Es ist eigentlich ein Data Field, wenn man es genau nimmt.
Also das, was ihr hier unten seht, ist das,
was
was meine App hier quasi macht.
Auf dem Garmin.
Und ich habe euch die alte App gezeigt und ihr seht jetzt die neue.
Und ihr werdet vielleicht feststellen,
das ist alles schon etwas besser als das,
was wir zusammen im Stream gebaut haben.
Erstens kannst du jetzt drei
Werte hier unten anzeigen, die
mehrere, alle drei Sekunden
mehrere Werte durchswitchen können.
Das muss man nicht machen, aber das kann man machen.
Ja, man kann zum Beispiel sagen,
ich möchte im ersten Data Field
äh, keine Ahnung, Watt, die man
tritt, anzeigen, plus Herzfrequenz
und sowas. Und hier beispielsweise
die Temperatur und wie schnell
man ist und was auch immer.
Und was noch viel cooler ist,
die Anzeige hier
zeigt dir an, in welcher
ähm, Herzfrequenzzone
du dich befindest
und hier in welcher Powerzone
man sich befindet.
Also sprich, die Farben
ändern sich auch hier.
Je nachdem in welcher Zone man ist.
Ich versuche euch das mal zu zeigen.
Activity Data.
Guck, jetzt ist es blau. Habt ihr das gesehen?
Jetzt ist es blau.
Also sprich, du musst dir auf diesen
Feldern gar keine Puls und Power
eigentlich anzeigen lassen, weil du siehst
deine Powerzone und deine Herzfrequenzzone
anhand dieses Strichs.
Das ist eigentlich sehr nice.
Das ist scheiße hier mit der Anordnung von dem Fenster.
Das ist sehr nice.
So, und was, und jetzt zeige ich euch mal, wie ich das ganze
gebaut hab. Ach ja, übrigens, ich hab es
auch schon mal, wer jetzt denkt, dass das nur im
Simulator funktioniert, es funktioniert
nicht nur im Simulator. Ich hab das
sideloaded auf meinen Garmin Edge und es
funktioniert auf dem Garmin ganz genauso wie hier.
Also, das
funktioniert wirklich. Ich bin sogar mal
10 Minuten die Treppe hoch und runter gesprintet.
Um zu gucken, ob das mit der Herzfrequenz funktioniert.
Wobei, mit der Herzfrequenz ist das ganze noch ein bisschen
verbuggt mit der Zonenanzeige.
Ich zeige euch einfach mal kurz, wie ich das gemacht hab.
Und dann,
eigentlich, was ich heute machen wollte, ist
noch mehr Datenfelder bauen,
was er anzeigen kann, weil aktuell
kann er nicht viel anzeigen. Aktuell
kann er Herzfrequenz,
Power,
Geschwindigkeit
und Temperatur. Mehr kann er nicht.
So, also das
Gesamte besteht aus
233 Zeilen
in der Datei
und dann haben wir noch eine HelperMC,
die ist fürs Calculaten von
für das
Powerzonen
zu Farbe umwandeln
und
Herzfrequenz zu Farbe umwandeln.
Aber so viel macht das nicht. Ich zeige euch das gleich noch im Detail.
Das wars. Also mehr gibt es nicht.
Es gibt eigentlich nur diese zwei Dateien.
Das hier ist Default und
das hier ist Default.
So, also wie das ganze funktioniert ist folgendes.
Also, das hier ist die Programmiersprache MonkeySea,
die wir hier in der Datei
verwenden,
die wir hier verwenden.
Also, wie das ganze funktioniert ist folgendes.
Also, wir haben hier
jetzt die Datei,
die wir hier verwenden,
die wir hier verwenden.
Und dann haben wir hier
die Datei,
die wir hier verwenden.
Und dann haben wir auch die Datei,
Und das hier ist die Programmiersprache MonkeySea,
weil Gamin.
Die sind der Meinung sie brauchen eine eigene
Programmiersprache. Und das ist ein wilder Verschnitt aus
Javascript,
äh, Lua,
ähm,
Ruby
und ein bisschen C,
Java und ein bisschen C, vielleicht?
Ganz, ganz weird.
Zumindest
Gamin-Plugins funktionieren folgendermaßen.
Man muss
Eine Klasse erstellen, einen View erstellen muss man. Also du musst eine Main Klasse im Endeffekt erstellen, die von Data Field erbt. Das reicht. Und da drinne musst du zwei Methoden überschreiben, damit das Ganze funktioniert.
Du brauchst OnLayout. Das wird immer aufgerufen, falls jemand beispielsweise Seiten wechselt auf dem Garmin oder die Größe der Felder ändert. Das ist wichtig, damit man weiß, wie groß denn das Datenfeld überhaupt ist.
Und die Größe des Datenfelds braucht man, um dann die Position für den Inhalt berechnen zu können. Dann muss man Initialize überschreiben. Das ist so ein Konstruktor im Endeffekt.
Dann kannst du, musst du aber nicht, Compute überschreiben.
Und du musst OnUpdate überschreiben.
OnUpdate und OnCompute wird vom Garmin Betriebssystem aufgerufen, wenn es denkt, dass man würdig ist, CPU-Zeit zu bekommen.
Allerdings wird Compute und OnUpdate unabhängig voneinander aufgerufen.
Das heißt, es ist sinnvoll, dadurch, dass man zweimal CPU-Zeit bekommt, nämlich einmal CPU-Zeit in Update und einmal CPU-Zeit in, äh, einmal CPU-Zeit bekommt zum Rendern in OnUpdate.
Und einmal CPU-Zeit bekommt in Compute, ist das sinnvoll, die Werte, die man anzeigen möchte, in Compute zu berechnen, sich zwischen zu speichern und in Update dann nur noch zu rendern.
So, und das ist das, was ich im Endeffekt hier auch mache.
In, in Compute berechne ich, ich zeige euch das gleich am Ende.
Im Compute berechne ich, was draufstehen soll und gucke, ob es switchen soll und sonst was und speichere mir das.
Und in Update.
Mal kurz angucken, weil das glaube ich so, das, das, das, was man machen muss, damit die Garmin-Sachen überhaupt was anzeigen.
Ähm, hat jemand von euch mal was gemacht mit, äh, eigenen Windows-Forms-Controls?
Oder hat jemand mal einen Canvas benutzt mit JavaScript von euch?
Oder habt ihr mal, boah, was gibt's noch, was so ähnlich funktioniert?
Aber in irgendeiner Art und Weise selbst mit irgendeinem UI-Framework Sachen gemalt.
Auf dem Bildschirm, anstatt fertige Controls zu benutzen.
Also, falls ja, dann werdet ihr wahrscheinlich Ähnlichkeiten erkennen.
Also, alle, die beispielsweise schon mal Canvas benutzt haben, HTML-Canvas und damit JavaScript reingemalt haben,
die werden wahrscheinlich Ähnlichkeiten erkennen.
Du bekommst hier einen Device-Kontext, also das ist das, warum auch immer es DC genannt wird,
du bekommst einen Device-Kontext, ein Device-Kontext ist im Prinzip ein, ja, nennen wir es mal so eine Art Pointer,
äh, zu deinem Grafikspeicher.
Stimmt nicht wirklich, aber ich glaube, da kann man sich das am besten runter vorstellen, ja.
Das ist ein Pointer zu deinem Grafikspeicher, in dem du dann quasi den Bildinhalt malen kannst, den du anzeigen willst.
Das heißt, am Anfang setzt man hier Vordergrundfarbe, Hintergrundfarbe, dann macht man alles weg.
Also, was hier passiert ist, er setzt Vordergrund und Hintergrund auf Weiß
und ich male.
Ein Rechteck in Weiß über mein komplettes Feld, sodass es einmal resettet wird, wenn es neu gezeichnet wird.
Aber ansonsten hast du manchmal das Problem, dass die Sachen ineinander laufen und sowas.
So, dann stellt er das Ganze wieder auf schwarzen Vordergrund, weißen Hintergrund um und fängt an zu malen.
Wurscht, was er hier genau macht.
Interessant ist das hier, das ist nämlich das, was den Text malt und die Einheiten malt.
Das hier malt den Text und das ganze Zeug hier drumherum.
Das ist nur dafür da, zu berechnen, wo der Text hin muss.
Weil ihr seht ja, das ist zentriert.
Sowohl horizontal zentriert, als auch vertikal zentriert.
Und die Einheiten sind immer unten links.
Das muss man irgendwie ausrechnen, wie das da hinkommt.
So, dann gibt es was Neues.
Das wusste ich letzte Mal noch nicht, wie das funktioniert, nämlich Icons malen.
Ihr seht, es gibt Icons.
Es gibt ein Herzsymbol und ein Blitz-Power-Symbol.
Die liegen hier irgendwo rum.
In dieser Resources-Drawables-XML.
Es gibt ein Herz-Icon und ein Bolt-Icon.
Und die Icons sind dort als 10x10 PNGs drin.
Als 10x10 PNGs drin.
High Res Pixel-Stells.
Das sind Tabler-Icons, das sind nicht die Garmin-Icons.
Tabler-Icons.
Ja.
Und damit das Ganze ein bisschen besser beherrscht.
Beherrschbar wird, im Vergleich zu dem, was ich das letzte Mal gebaut habe.
Habe ich das auch noch alles aufgeteilt in unterschiedliche Strukturen und Klassen in dem Fall, um die Daten zu speichern.
Also es gibt Data-Field-Section.
Das ist eins von diesen Kästchen hier.
Und dann gibt es noch die Daten an sich, die angezeigt werden.
Und das kann man überschreiben und einstellen, was er denn machen soll.
Also zum Beispiel dieses Feld.
Hier neben.
Was den Puls anzeigt.
Das sieht so aus.
Das ist alles.
Das ist relativ übersichtlich.
Es gibt eine Update-Methode.
An der Stelle guckt er einfach nach.
Kann das Gerät die aktuelle Herzfrequenz auslesen?
Wenn ja, dann holen wir uns die aktuelle Herzfrequenz, formatieren die als Zahl und dann schreiben wir das in den Text rein.
Und dann beim nächsten Update wird es gerendert.
Fertig.
So sieht das aus.
Also ich glaube, Chetke, ich glaube, versteht man eigentlich ganz gut so einen einzelnen Abschnitt.
Ach ja, und der Trick, ich glaube, an der Stelle, dem können wahrscheinlich die meisten folgen, oder?
Der holt sich das Icon hier, der stellt die Unit ein und hier unten liest er halt aus und merkt sich den Text, was es sein muss.
Dementsprechend ist es auch relativ einfach, das zu erweitern.
Aber Trick 17, ihr seht ja hier, das wechselt.
Beziehungsweise das kann wechseln.
Das wechselt aktuell alle drei Sekunden von, in dem Fall hier von Leistung auf Puls.
Und das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Es gibt hier ein Array mit Sections und da seht ihr schon, in der ersten Section, also in dem ersten Block, gibt es Heartrate und Power-Info.
Hier gibt es im zweiten Block, gibt es Temperatur und Speed-Info.
Und im dritten gibt es nur Power-Data-Info.
Das ist dementsprechend, wechselt der dritte Block auch nicht.
Aber die ersten zwei Blöcke wechseln zwischen den verschiedenen Werten, die sie anzeigen sollen.
Man könnte da übrigens auch drei reinschreiben, aber da wird es langsam ein bisschen unübersichtlich.
Und er wechselt alle drei Sekunden das Feld.
Werden Emojis unterstützt?
Nicht direkt.
Emojis kannst du nur als Bilder einbilden.
Also die haben kein Image-Fonts, der Emojis kann.
Das kannst du machen.
Ja.
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür.
Das kannst du machen.
Und zwar, Data-Info unterstützt folgende Sachen.
Eine Unit, eine Color, die ich noch nicht irgendwo verwende, aber die könnte man verwenden.
Ein Icon, was ich auch nirgendswo verwende und einen Text.
In dem Fall ist der Text 200 und die Unit W.
Heißt also, man könnte sagen, wir können das mal machen exemplarisch, dass ihr seht,
oder hoffe ich zumindest, dass das, wie ich das gebaut habe, eigentlich relativ simpel ist.
Gehen wir mal hier auf Speed Data Info.
Ja, also was wir jetzt machen können, das ist, wann gibt es einen Dark Mode?
Nachdem das Display draußen verwendet wird und es gibt einen Dark Mode, es gibt einen Dark Mode, aber ich glaube, niemand verwendet den.
Und aktuell rendert das ja auch Hard-Coded auf schwarzem Vordergrund, weißem Hintergrund.
Also, also was?
So, Alter.
Kann man mal ein Bild, please, vorne bleiben jetzt, sonst sieht das doch kacke aus, man.
So, also was du jetzt natürlich machen könntest, um unterschiedliche, also Ligat, um unterschiedliche Farben anzuzeigen,
könntest du zum Beispiel hier die rausholen, Info Current Speed, dann mal hier War Speed
und dann könntest du sowas machen wie, sagen wir mal, If, das ist also von der Idee her ist eigentlich ganz einfach,
If Speed größer, keine Ahnung.
20, dann Color gleich Graphics Red, äh, Red, Color Red.
Und dann wird die, wird das, wird das rot, über 20 kmh, oder, äh, soweit von der Idee her, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das Rendern von der Farbe da schon eingebaut habe, aber.
Also von der Idee her sollte das dann so funktionieren, guck mal, wie schnell der sein kann, 8 kmh, sagen wir mal, größer, 5.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob ich das eingebaut habe, dass man, äh, dass er die Farbe rendert, gucken wir mal.
Probieren wir mal aus, wenn es nicht geht, können wir das mal schnell einbauen.
Das, das schaffen wir in 20 Minuten, bis ich was essen muss.
Das muss, ich muss nichts essen, aber ich hab Hunger.
Und Speed, äh, zeigt er nicht an.
Okay, aber er, er könnte, er könnte es theoretisch, er könnte es theoretisch anzeigen.
Dann gehen wir doch mal an die Stelle, wo das Ganze gerendert wird.
Hier.
Ja.
Data Field Sections.
Draw Text.
Ja.
Im Prinzip easy.
Eigentlich müsste ich sagen, Draw Text, äh, Graphics Color is Data Color.
So, und dann sollte das schon, also ich hab's ja auch nicht gebildet, ich kann nur, ich muss ja einmal kompilieren.
Und dann sollte eigentlich die Speed Information, da sollte der Speed, wenn er größer, 5.
5 ist, eigentlich jetzt in Rot sein.
Schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Bin mir da noch etwas unschlüssig.
Ja, ja, ja.
Pock, oder?
Und am Ende würde ich sagen, stellen wir das nochmal.
Wir sollen das dann wieder zurückstellen, weil hier wird die Einheit, sollen wir die, Chat, sollen wir die Einheit mit Rot malen?
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, die Einheit sollte immer einheitlich in, in Schwarz sein.
Color Black, Color White, ja.
Oh.
Machen wir, machen wir es lieber so.
Bild.
Laden wir mal neu.
Also das kann man machen.
Ich, ich, ich hab bisher absichtlich keine Farben eingebaut für die, für die, äh, für die Zahlen, weil ich finde, es wird ein bisschen unübersichtlich.
Stellt euch mal vor, das hat Farben, das hat Farben, das hat Farben, das und das hat Farben.
Da blickst du ja gar nicht mehr durch.
Ja, so, jetzt hast du hier das.
Weil die hier ändern sich ja auch, je nach Herzfrequenzregion und wie viel Power, wie viel Watt man gerade tritt.
Ja.
Aber von der Idee her finde ich es nicht schlecht.
Theoretisch könnte man sogar hingehen und sagen, man macht zwei verschiedene Data Fields, einmal Speed mit Color und einmal Speed ohne Color.
Oder irgendwie eine Option beim, äh, am Anfang, ob man das, ob man das haben möchte oder nicht.
Ja.
Aber was ist denn ganz gut?
Also Speed, sagt, sagt mir mal ein paar sinnige Werte.
Also wir reden hier nicht zu viel.
Wir reden von Meilen pro Stunde, weil wir sind nicht im Kona Land, sondern von Kilometern pro Stunde.
Sagt mir mal sinnvolle, sinnvolle Werte.
Also Color zur Auswahl haben wir Grau, Grün, Blau, Orange, Rot.
Ja, siehste, ihr seid schon viel zu advanced.
Ich würde das theoretisch so handhaben, dass wenn, sollte ich das jemals in den Garmin Store pushen,
dann könnte ich das konfigurierbar machen.
Also wir reden über die App.
Nicht Durchschnitt, aktuelle Geschwindigkeit.
Wie sieht es aus, wenn die Sonne scheint?
Sieht man das Display gut?
Ja, das haben die gut gemacht.
Das haben die gut gemacht.
Selbst wenn voll die Sonne drauf scheint, erkennt man es gut.
Ja, also man muss es auf jeden Fall konfigurierbar machen.
Aber wir können ja mal sagen, wir können ja mal sagen, also der Default Speed, ja.
Der Default Speed ist ganz klar Graphics, äh, Graphics Black.
Ja, weil, boah.
Da kann man sagen, wenn das Speed, wenn das Speed über 10 ist oder so.
Aber so viel zeigt er nicht an.
Wenn das Speed über 10 ist, dann, ja.
Deswegen, ich finde bei Speed ist es relativ unsinnig, da irgendwas mit Farbe zu machen.
Man könnte höchstens sagen, hey, Speed, Speed ist alles, alles, machen wir in schwarz.
Wir können dann sagen, über 25, machen wir Color Orange.
Und, ähm, ja, if.
Ja, if.
Und wenn der, und wenn der über 30 ist.
Wobei, das ist jetzt super, oh, okay.
Und wenn der über 30 ist, dann sind wir schon, sind wir schon super, super schnell, wenn's Color Red, so.
Das, das könnte man auch machen.
Wenn du bergab fährst.
Eigentlich finde ich es eine gute, Leute, das finde ich ist eine gute Idee.
Das könnte man so als Warnung für bergrunter fahren, äh.
Sagen wir mal über 50, ja.
Sagen wir über 45, komm.
Über 45, über 45 ist rot.
Und übrigens, wir müssen raus.
Wir müssen was umdrehen.
Sonst, ähm, macht das, macht das komische Sachen.
Ja, also, wenn Speed über, hm, über 45 ist.
Wenn Speed über 40 ist, ist es orange.
Wenn Speed über 40 ist, ist es rot.
Letztendlich, wenn man, wenn, wenn ich das machen möchte, dass das irgendjemand außer mir verwendet.
Was ich eigentlich gar nicht vorhabe.
Dann, dann könnt, dann kann ich die Sachen nicht hardcoden.
Sondern ich muss die konfigurierbar machen über die Garmin App.
Und da können die Leute selbst eintragen, was sie eintragen wollen.
Dann müsste ich hier im Konstruktor laden.
Weiß auch nicht, wie das geht.
Gibt's dann wahrscheinlich irgendeine Konfig, Konfig-Klasse.
Wo man das rauslesen kann.
Und dann, ja.
Aber Chat, es ist eine sehr gute Idee.
Und am besten noch 30er Zone, ja.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob man im Ort ist oder nicht.
Ich weiß ja nicht, ob man im Ort ist.
Ich glaube nicht, dass man.
Komm mal, Garmin SDK.
Ich bin mir nicht, ich bin mir, ich bin mir relativ sicher, das kann man nicht.
Abfragen.
Äh.
Apidox.
Du würdest bei Temperaturen was.
Sehr gute Idee.
Ja, ja, das finde ich nice.
Aber hier.
Eiswarnung.
Da könnte man sogar, da könnte man sogar einen Schneeflocken-Symbol anzeigen lassen.
Das habe ich mir auch.
Das ist auch eine Sache, was ich mir noch überlegt habe, was mega cool wäre.
Also es wären zwei Sachen, wären auch wirklich cool.
Wenn man ein kombiniertes Battery-Icon anzeigen lassen könnte.
Also sprich ein Batterie-Icon.
Der immer den niedrigsten Stand anzeigt.
Weil, seriously, man hat mehr Batterien als man denkt.
Man hat Batteriestand vom Garmin.
Man hat Batteriestand vom, von der Schaltung.
Man hat Batteriestand von der Lampe.
Man hat Batteriestand theoretisch vom, vom Pedal.
Man hat Batteriestand vom Rücklicht.
Ja.
Und solche Sachen.
Das wäre mega cool.
Aber leider bekommt man die Infos bei Garmin nicht.
Es wäre mega cool, wenn man die Infos abfragen könnte.
Und ein so Combined-Battery-Icon machen könnte.
Was quasi, sobald eines davon niedrig ist, es einfach anzeigt.
Ne, für den Icon kannst du nicht anzeigen, von welchem Gerät.
Aber sobald es niedrig ist, kannst du ja durchgucken.
Aber das geht eh nicht, weil man die Infos nicht aus dem Garmin rausbekommt.
Ja.
Also ich glaube auch nicht, dass man...
Location, gucken wir mal.
Location.
Location, was man da abfragen kann.
Position Info.
GPS Timestamp.
Speed.
Kennt ihr irgendeine Web-API, wo ich eine Geo-Position übergeben kann und ich bekomme
zurück, wie schnell man dort fahren darf oder ob man in einem Ort ist oder nicht.
Mir fällt, mir fällt da keine ein.
Speed Limit-API.
Gibt es sowas?
Open Street Maps hat sowas?
Wirklich?
Ok, ok, Google hat das.
Aber das kostet halt wieder abfuck.
Viel.
Ja, ja.
Hat Open Street Maps sowas?
Wäre das Wetter nicht sinn...
Doch, doch, doch.
Es geht jetzt nicht entweder oder.
Man kann das alles machen, ja.
Wetter finde ich persönlich jetzt nicht so geil.
Ausführlich Wetter wäre als Icon irgendwie praktisch.
Ja, dass man Wetter Icon anzeigen lassen kann.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich will es ja nicht übertreiben.
Ich will das haben, was ich, was ich benutze und ein bisschen rumspielen, ja.
Wie kriegt man das Speed Limit von Open Street Maps?
Overpass?
Gibt es...
Die Seite...
Guck mal, die Antwort ist von 2013.
Das gibt es wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr.
Oder?
Overpass-API.
Ach, tatsächlich.
Was ist das denn?
13 Jahre her.
Nice.
Database Engine to query Open Street Maps Data.
Okay, das ist natürlich nice, wenn das funktioniert.
Ich, ich curle das mal kurz.
Curl.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Ist überhaupt HTTPS?
Nee, HTTP.
Moment, was hat der für Schmerzen?
Äh...
Chatgear...
Was hat, was hat der für Schmerzen jetzt?
Ähm...
That's using XAP?
XAP?
What?
Modern Alternative, which can use XML.
Ja, okay, nice.
Moment, das geht...
Wie, wie mache ich jetzt eine ordentliche Abfrage da?
Muss man das ein...
Muss man das vielleicht escapen?
Dass Bash da was komisches macht?
Nee.
Ja, gut, nice.
Wegerd.
Komm, Wegerd macht das.
Easy.
Wegerd.
Ah, Wegerd hat kein Problem damit.
Okay, nice.
Schauen wir da mal rein.
Pfunz.
Wegerd hat kein Problem damit.
Okay, nice.
Schauen wir da mal rein.
Pfunz.
Ah, funktioniert.
Okay, das wäre natürlich richtig big brain, Leute.
Man macht nen Webrequest...
Das mache ich aber jetzt nicht.
Weil man...
Alle, tja, keine Ahnung, 10 Sekunden oder so.
Dann muss derjenige halt sein Handy in Reichweite haben, ne?
Man kann nämlich auch von dem Gerät nen Webrequest über die App auf dem Handy triggern.
Man macht nen Webrequest yakaulich.
Request, alle 15 Sekunden
ruft das Speed Limit ab
und wenn man über dem
Speed Limit ist, wird's rot.
Eigentlich
eine richtig coole Idee.
Passt schon ein bisschen zu advanced,
aber
da muss ich mal, auf die Idee ist
doch schon irgendjemand anderes gekommen.
Store
Speed Limit.
Ja, siehste,
siehste,
dachte ich mir.
Ja, Speed Limit.
Ein einfaches Datenfeld, das eine Farbanzeige
geräuchert, während es über
oder einen bestimmten Tempolimit...
Achso, Edge?
Ja, Marker Feature.
Ja.
Ich schreib das mal auf, weil
das Ding ist halt die,
ich mein, das ist easy zu machen
mit dem Marker, ja.
Mit dem Marker ist easy zu machen,
aber
dann ist es nicht so komfortabel.
Also was man easy machen könnte, ist
Knopf drücken,
dann schickt es ein Web Request
an irgendeinen Server von dir
und
mit den Koordinaten.
So, dann musstest du halt im Endeffekt
das irgendwie selbst zusammenfudeln danach.
Denn
also
die
Route, also das unterstützt
das Garmin-Zeug halt nicht, dass du irgendwelche Marker
einfügst.
Man müsste das,
man müsste das halt irgendwie
über einen Umweg machen.
Das sind, ich mein, die Koordinaten locken
wäre nicht das Problem.
Aber das halt dann schön zu koordinieren,
äh, zu kombinieren mit der Map im Anschluss
ist dann wahrscheinlich gar nicht so easy.
Wäre interessant, welche API die da verwenden.
Ja.
Äh, vermutlich gar keine API, weil
die schreiben ja hier,
man muss das Tempolimit festlegen
im Vorfeld.
Also im Prinzip ist es so, dass man das Tempolimit festlegen muss, im Vorfeld.
Also, es wundert mich, dass das noch keiner gebaut hat.
Aber gut, permanente Web-Requests ist wahrscheinlich nicht so geil, ne?
Aber das hier ist doch eigentlich ganz cool, was die hier haben.
Äh, wget-o, wget-name-download, wie kommt man bei, wget, war das minus-o?
Oder, Chatki, ihr seid doch, ihr wisst doch sowas immer aus dem Kopf.
Ja, wget-different-file-name, wie geht das?
Minus, ach, minus-groß-o ist es nicht, minus-klein-groß-o, keckel-punkt, Moment, welchem Ordner bin ich denn hier überhaupt?
Ähm, cd-downloads-garmin-pog, keckel-punkt-xml, ja.
Okay, das funktioniert, das finde ich mega-nice, dass das klappt.
Wir testen mal was, ob das stimmt.
Wir gehen jetzt mal hier hin.
Äh, Maps, Google, Frankfurt, Zeitung.
File oder so, da suchen wir uns jetzt mal die Koordinaten raus.
Ja, da kann man, oder irgendwo hier, wo man Auto fahren darf.
Da, so.
Und, hallo?
Google, darf ich, darf ich please, please markieren, ja, ist das möglich?
Hä?
What?
Leute, eben hat's doch, eben hat's doch angezeigt, die Koordinaten.
Warum zeigt es jetzt die Koordinaten nicht?
Ach, hier, das ist doch.
Äh.
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Warum sind das, und warum ist das falsch rum?
Muss es umgedreht machen, oder?
Ich muss sagen, das ist immer Komma getrennt.
Also, ich muss sagen, zuerst das, dann das.
Das soll eine Box werden, also im Prinzip dann hier eins drauf, ne, und da irgendwie noch eins drauf.
Oh.
Oder auch nicht.
Das ist das falsche Korts-Format.
Ernsthaft, was muss es denn sein?
Sind's einfach nur vertauscht gewesen.
Also, das, was ich da gerade abgefragt hab, funktioniert schon mal nett.
Ah, keine Ahnung.
Damit OpenStreetMaps bin ich, was so API-Sachen angeht, ja eh ein bisschen auf dem Kriegsfuß.
Geht mal die Koordinaten aus dem Beispiel-Link ein.
Geht nicht.
Ja gut, das ist ja auch falsch rum bei denen.
Ja doch, passt doch.
Nö, ist richtig, ist richtig.
Hm, ich hab ja meins auch umgedreht.
Aber da kriegt man offensichtlich nichts, kein Tempolimit von Frankfurt.
Naja.
Aber, okay, keine Ahnung.
Das ist auch echt nur Spielerei jetzt.
Was, was gibt's sonst noch?
Developer hier.
Lost.
Nokia.
Okay, nice.
Ja, okay, da müsste man echt mal schauen, wie man das, wie man das Ganze raus, rausbekommt.
Über den RepriQuest könnte man das Ganze noch machen, schön ist es allerdings nicht.
Aber die Idee mit dem Wetter-Icon finde ich ganz gut.
Und dass man einen festgelegten Speed, festgelegten Speed machen kann, wo man dann sagt, irgendwie über, über 40 orange, über 45, finde ich gut.
Ja, ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Leute, ich kann echt schlecht tippen mit dem Finger.
Glücklich, Sack.
Und, und das, die Idee mit der Icon.
Die Idee mit dem Eiswarnung finde ich auch sehr, sehr pock.
Muss nur mal gucken, wie man das am besten einbaut.
Weil so ein komplettes, so ein komplettes Feld ist natürlich schon ein bisschen, bisschen übertrieben.
Vielleicht, vielleicht, das ist nur mal so eine Idee.
Vielleicht könnte ich auch irgendwie noch einen Icon, so eine, so eine Art Tray, Tray-Icon-Sache.
Dass man irgendwie noch drei extra Icons.
Anzeigen lassen kann oder so.
Die was, ja, keine Ahnung.
Muss ich mir was überlegen.
Aber da fällt mir echt grad nichts ein.
Ich hab, oh, Hunger.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Heute war nicht so viel Burger-Stelz.
Irgendwie war heute der Mega-Side-Track-Stream schlechthin dran.
Side, Side-Trackser hoch 10.
Wir haben zwei Stunden Side-Getrackt und jetzt 51 Minuten ein bisschen was gebastelt.
Und, äh, Verteilung, äh, lohnt sich das überhaupt zu committen?
Ja, warum nicht, ja.
Get, Commit, A, Minus, M, Keck, Waiting.
Dafür warst du umso produktiver nebenbei.
Das ist doch extrem.
Oh, Get, Push.
Was hab ich denn hier?
Get, Push, Origin, Keckle.
Alles klar.
Oh.
Hab ich.
Hab ich mir HTTPS.
PP geklont, oder was?
Ey, das ist ja richtig, richtig PP-Ger, Mann.
Moment.
Äh.
Wo ist der Knopf, um auf SSH umzuschalten?
Chat-Gil?
Ist er, ist der weg, wenn man nicht eingeloggt ist?
Das ist jetzt aber neu, oder?
Get, Remote, RM, Origin.
Get, Remote.
Remote, Add, Origin, ja, so.
Und jetzt muss ich allerdings sagen, oh, wie sieht das aus?
SSH?
Nee, Git.
Wie sieht das richtig aus?
Kann man hier mal nachgucken?
Egal.
Oder irgendwie Github, Add, oder?
Meine Güte.
Git, Add, Github.com?
Warte mal, bin ich, bin ich auf meinem zweiten Browser hier noch eingeloggt?
Nee.
Natürlich nicht.
Das wäre jetzt auch zu einfach.
Warum machen die so was?
Warum machen die so was denn weg?
Das ist so richtig abfuck jetzt von Microsoft, Mann.
Einfach so.
Git, Add, Github, com.
Und dann was?
Doppelpunkt, wo bloß?
Slash, DataChamp, Garmin.
Git kommt wahrscheinlich weg, oder?
Schauen wir mal, ob das jetzt, ob das jetzt so stimmt.
Äh, hinten Git.
Okay.
Push.
Nice.
Hat funktioniert.
Gut.
Äh, DataChamp, Garmin ist da.
Vor zwei Minuten gepusht.
Ich bin gerade am Einrichten eines CDNs für Images.
Krass, wie viel Standorte hast du so?
Die auf einer Webseite eingebettet sind.
Wie lange dauert es denn üblicherweise, bis Requests tatsächlich gecached werden?
Ich hab nur onke...
Hä?
Das kommt drauf an, was du eingestellt hast.
Ei, mein Kabel fuckt mich ab wieder.
Was ist das hier?
Moment, Moment.
Ah, okay.
Jetzt geht's so.
Oh, stimmt.
Ich mach das jetzt.
Ja, ja, ich guck gleich.
Hab ich grad vergessen.
Hahaha.
Ich sag doch, erinnere mich dran, wenn ich's vergesse.
Ich wusste, dass ich das wieder vergesse bis abends.
Äh.
Also, Images und so, das ist nach dem ersten Request gecached.
Also, lokal bei dir.
Ansonsten, ansonsten weiß ich nicht genau, was du, was du machst.
Und wie die Architektur aussieht.
Keine Ahnung.
Moin, Fips.
Du kommst genau richtig.
Ich geh jetzt was auf.
Ich geh, ich geh jetzt auf was essen.
Geiler Satz.
Also, ich weiß gar nicht.
Also, nur weil du nen CDN hast, heißt doch lange nicht, dass überhaupt dein Browser dahin
geht.
Und wenn, und wenn er dahin geht, dann ruft er immer von dort ab.
Oder wie jetzt?
Oder was jetzt?
Hä?
Habt ihr ne Idee fürs nächste YouTube-Video-Thema?
Also, ich hab eins.
Ich hab eins.
Ich wollt, ich wollt mal wieder ein bisschen irgende, irgendeine lustige Story erzählen.
Ich hab ja so ne, so ne Themenliste, wo Sachen draufstehen.
Ein bisschen was Lustiges wieder mal zur Abwechslung erzählen, was so die letzten Jahre über passiert
ist.
Aber das hat halt nicht so wirklich Substanz.
Das ist immer mal ganz, ganz nice.
Habt ihr irgendeine gute Idee für irgendwas bisschen?
Weil ich hab ja schon lange nichts mehr gemacht.
Ich müsste echt mal wieder was machen.
Und ich hab ne riesenlange Themenliste, aber irgendwie ist mir das da gerade nicht so nach
irgendwas.
Du hast das Wort.
Viel Spaß.
Wir haben die ersten zwei Stunden nichts gemacht.
Okay.
Aber ich hab Hunger, Leute.
Ich geh jetzt was essen.
Wir sehen uns.
Macht's gut.
Spätestens morgen früh.
Denkt dran.
Morgen früh wieder irgendwie 9 Uhr oder so.
8.30 Uhr, 9 Uhr.
Aufwachen, streamen.
Morgen früh muss ich erst ne Runde rennen.
Und, aber keine neue Rekordrunde oder so.
Ganz normal.
6,2 Kilo.
Oder, oder Chat, wenn ich morgen, habt ihr was dagegen, wenn ich morgen erst 9.15 Uhr
da bin?
Ist mir eigentlich ziemlich wurscht, ob ihr was dagegen, aber ich frag trotzdem mal.
Weil, dann könnte ich die große Runde rennen.
Die ist mit, mit ner Schleife an die 10 Kilometer, anstatt 6,2.
Hab ich schon ne Weile nicht mehr gemacht.
Wär eigentlich mal wieder an der Zeit.
Stream Zwift.
Äh, Zwift rennen kann ich nicht.
Ich hab nix, wo man da rennen kann mit.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man da überhaupt rennt mit.
Braucht man irgend so ein Laufband oder so.
Da hab ich gar keinen Platz für hier.
Im, im Arbeitszimmer.
GoPro mitnehmen.
Oh, ne.
Mit GoPro rennen hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Außerdem werde ich dann eventuell noch geleakt oder so, wenn ich da irgendwo rumrenne.
Leakt?
Zieh mir einfach meine fette Sonnenbrille auf, auch wenn scheiß Wetter ist.
Dann ist es egal, ob ich geleakt werde.
Ist hier jemand, der Vodafone DS Lite anschaut und Erfahrung mit Heim-Server freigab?
Ja, meine Erfahrung ist, kannst du vergessen.
Weil das rein technisch gesehen nicht funktioniert.
Wenn du NAT auf Anbieter-Seite hast, hast du gelitten.
Dafür kannst du IPv6 ohne Probleme verwenden.
Weil du einen vollwertigen IPv6-Anschluss hast.
Aber das bringt dir nix, wenn du nicht per IPv6 von außen drankommst.
Ähm, also es gibt natürlich Möglichkeiten, Port-Weiterleitungen zu machen.
Auch bei DS Lite.
Aber das braucht immer einen Endpunkt irgendwo im Internet.
Mit einer Public IPv4-Adresse.
Also wenn du dir zum Beispiel einen günstigen Server mietest mit IPv4-Endpunkt.
Dann kannst du einen Tunnel bauen zwischen dir daheim und dem Server.
Und dann einen Port vom Server weiterleiten irgendwo heim.
Weil du ja dann quasi den Verbindungsaufbau von innen initiierst zu deinem Server.
Und dann der Port weiterleiten. Das geht.
Aber weiterleiten direkt auf, sagen wir mal, den Raspberry Pi bei dir daheim.
Ist nicht möglich mit DS Lite.
IPv4, wohlgemerkt.
Nur über Umwege mit Sachen im Internet.
Ja, oder Cloudflare oder was auch immer.
Du brauchst auf jeden Fall was im Internet als Endpunkt.
So die Sachen, die Zeiten von
Ich gehe in meinen Router, stelle Port-Weiterleitungen ein auf die interne Raspberry Pi IP.
Port 8443 oder was auch immer.
Die sind vorbei mit DS Lite. Kannste klicken.
Es sei denn, IPv6 mit IPv6 funktioniert es dann ohne Probleme.
Aber wen juckt IPv6, ne?
In meisten Fällen juckt einen das ja nicht so richtig.
Ihr kennt ja meine Meinung zu IPv6.
Also, also, nein, das ist falsch.
Nicht meine Meinung zu IPv6, sondern meine Meinung zu IPv6 Verbreitung und wie sich das durchsetzen wird.
Aus dem gleichen Netzwerk, doch, das ist kein Problem.
Aus dem gleichen Netzwerk geht, geht.
Egal ob IPv6 oder IPv4.
Dann musst du aber auch keine Ports weiterleiten, weil innerhalb des gleichen Netzwerkes spielt weder Port-Weiterleitung, noch Routing, noch sonst was irgendwie eine Rolle.
Dann hängst du beide, da hängen beide Kisten am gleichen Switch, im gleichen Netz.
Und dann kannst du einfach auf die interne IP zugreifen.
Das, das ist, das ist egal.
Das hat, das hat mit DS Lite nichts zu tun.
Aus dem gleichen Netz?
Aus dem gleichen Netz über das Internet.
Wie soll das, wie soll das funktionieren?
Ach so, Moment.
Du meinst, äh, du meinst, reden wir mal von, reden wir mal in IPv4, ja, weil es einfacher ist.
Du meinst, wenn dein Server bei dir daheim 192.168.0.1.24 hat und du hast irgendwo bei einem Freund auch jemand, der einen Rechner hat in diesem Netz.
Und dann übers Internet, weil das das gleiche Netz ist.
Oder wie?
Ne, das ist, das funktioniert nicht.
Da ist ja das Internet dazwischen.
Und beides sind, äh, interne Internets.
Und bei IPv6, bei IPv6 kannst du halt jedem Toaster eine Public IP geben, die geroutet wird.
Aber dann musst du immer noch, also im gleichen Netz sind die dann trotzdem nicht.
Aber ja, wenn die, also im gleichen Netz funktioniert prinzipiell immer, weil da nie geroutet wird.
Aber sobald du routen müsstest, weil irgendwas dazwischen ist, dann geht das nicht.
Also, mir ist nicht gut.
Also, mir ist nicht ganz klar, wie es ausschaut bei dir.
Dass du denkst, das müsste funktionieren.
Das erschließt sich mir jetzt noch gar nicht.
Also, wenn du ein Handy hast mit IPv6-Adresse und du hast ein Raspberry Pi mit IPv6-Adresse, dann können die miteinander reden.
Sofern nicht irgendeine Firewall das Ganze blockiert.
Also, wir reden jetzt nicht von irgendeiner Link-Local-Adresse oder sonst was.
Ähm, jo.
Ja, also das ist wahrscheinlich das einfachste, wenn du wirklich Ports weiterleiten willst.
Ja.
Also, meine Lösung für Port-Weiterleitung, wenn es kurz, wenn es simpel und schnell funktionieren soll, ist folgendes.
Also, gehen wir mal von einem DSLite-Anschluss aus.
Wäre folgendes.
Ich miete mir einen ganz, ganz billigen Server.
Ja, so einen, sagen wir mal einen 1-Euro-Server bei IONOS für 1 Euro im Monat.
Dann mache ich den SSH-Tunnel auf, genau, mache ich den SSH-Tunnel minus G und leite den Port weiter.
Also, ich würde dann sowas hier in der Richtung machen wie, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich das aus dem Kopf zusammenkriege.
SSH minus G minus R.
Ähm, dann sagen wir 8443.
Weitergeleitet auf 192.168.
Ja.
Dann mache ich 192.168 hier irgendwie 0.1.
Äh, Port, ja, 443.
Und dann maxed mein Server 0w.de.
So, und ich glaube, das müsste dann funktionieren, wenn ich das jetzt richtig aus dem Kopf.
Ja, das stimmt, das geht nur für TCP-Traffic.
Ja, das ist richtig.
So, was das jetzt macht.
Wenn ich es richtig im Kopf habe, bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Das macht ein Port, also, das lockt sich remote auf diesem Server ein.
Öffnet dort Port 8443.
Ähm, also 0.0.0.0 8443.
Also, global.
Also, halt nicht nur an Localhost gebunden.
Macht das Port 8443 für alle auf.
Und alles, was in diesen Port geht, wird über den Tunnel geschickt und am Tunnel-Endpunkt weitergeleitet an diese lokale IP diesen Port.
So.
So, ich glaube, das ist richtig.
Das wäre für mich die simpelste Variante für eine Port-Weiterleitung, wenn ich sowas mal zackig umgehen müsste und es sich um TCP-Traffic handelt.
Was man natürlich auch machen kann ist, intern dann einen WireGuard oder OpenVPN-Server haben, auf den man weiterleitet den Port.
Also, damit es klappt, muss der...
Damit es klappt, muss Client und Server auf gleichem Protokoll sein.
Ja.
Das ist prinzipiell erstmal so pauschal gesagt korrekt.
Natürlich gibt es Varianten, das zu umgehen, aber in der Regel ist das so.
Ja.
Aber da ich doch von meinem Heimrechner aus zugreife, bin ich doch über die gleiche IPv6-Adresse unterwegs oder bin ich drum...
Ach, jetzt weiß ich, was du meinst.
Willst du denn auf die IPv6-Adresse von deinem Router zugreifen oder auf die IPv6-Adresse von deinem Raspberry Pi?
Ja.
Also, wenn du auf die IPv6-Adresse von deinem Raspberry Pi zugreifen möchtest, dann sollte das funktionieren, sofern...
Sofern das Netzwerkgerät dazwischen nicht irgendwas blockt.
Alternativ kannst du auch einfach nicht die...
Nicht diese...
Oh, IPv6-Leute, da bin ich der übelste Kack-Noob.
Alternativ kannst du auch, um lokal drauf zuzugreifen, nicht die...
Wie heißt denn das?
Die eigentliche IPv6-Adresse nehmen, sondern die Local IPv6-Adresse.
Ist es bei IPv6 nicht so, dass du standardmäßig mehrere Adressen bekommst?
Ne Local...
Also, so ne Link-Local-Randomized-Adresse und ne...
Ach, ich hab keine Ahnung von IPv6, Mann.
Du kriegst, glaube ich, ne automatische IPv6-Adresse, die quasi für alle quasi in diesem Netzwerk, an diesem Port per Switch irgendwie gelten.
Und du kriegst noch eine, die rootbar ist.
Och, kein Schimmer, Mann. Ich hab keine Ahnung davon, ne.
Ich hab deutlich zu wenig mit IPv6 gemacht.
Aber prinzipiell geht das, was du hier schreibst.
Also du kannst...
Also du hast... Dein Heimrechner hat auf jeden Fall nicht die gleiche IPv6-Adresse.
Weil entweder kriegt dein Raspberry Pi ne eigene IPv6-Adresse und dein Rechner ne eigene IPv6-Adresse.
Dann können die ohne Probleme miteinander reden.
Sofern das Netzwerkgerät dazwischen nichts blockt.
Sollten sie im gleichen Netz sein, haben beide Geräte trotzdem unterschiedliche IP-Adressen, können aber direkt miteinander reden, weil Link-Local-IPv6-Adresse...
Möchtest du sowas wie Port-Weiterleitung machen, also nämlich die IP deines Routers nehmen und quasi weiterleiten auf die interne IPv6-Adresse von deinem Raspberry Pi auf einem speziellen Port,
hab ich keine Ahnung, wie man das konfiguriert, aber müsste theoretisch auch gehen.
Aber dann hat trotzdem dein Heimrechner ne andere IP.
Ich hab kein Schimmer, wie es genau ist bei IPv6.
Ok, drei Stück kriegt man. Link-Local, Global-Unique und Internet.
Siehst du mal, bisschen was ist doch noch hängen geblieben.
Aber zu wenig Plan.
Also du kannst auf jeden Fall...
Wenn die am gleichen Switch hängen...
Kriegt...
Und ich geh mal davon aus, dass diese zwei Sachen am gleichen Switch hängen bei dir.
Dann müsste dein Heimrechner und dein Raspberry Pi eine IPv6-Link-Local-Adresse bekommen haben.
Woran erkennt man ne Link-Local-Adresse, Leute?
Ähm...
Die haben doch so ein spezielles Format, ne?
Ja, FE80, genau.
Also sowohl dein Rechner, als auch dein Raspberry Pi, die müssten so ne FE80-Adresse bekommen haben.
Nachdem du den Port hochgefahren hast.
So, und mit dieser FE80-Adresse kannst du zwischen den zwei Kisten, wenn die am gleichen Switch hängen, kommunizieren miteinander.
Und das ist nicht die Public IPv6-Adresse von dir.
Sondern die Link...
Warum kann ich das nicht copy...
Ey!
Was ist das?
Copy ist ausgegraut. What the fuck?
Jetzt geht's wieder. Ok, was auch immer.
Ja, jetzt meine ich ja alle Geräte, die am gleichen Switch hängen.
Da funktioniert das.
Also zwischen zwei Geräten direkt.
Also wenn die am Switch hängen, geht's ja auch.
Da merkt der IPv6 nix von.
Oder?
Ich wüsste zwar nicht wie, aber sicher bin ich mir bei IPv6 prinzipiell nicht.
Ja.
Also du müsstest so ne FE80-Adresse bekommen haben.
Sowohl beim Raspberry Pi, als auch auf deinem Rechner.
Und da kannst du zwischen kommunizieren.
Direkt.
Zwischen den zwei Kisten.
Hat denn...
Die Kiste auf die dein...
Also der Raspberry Pi, auf dem dein Nextcloud läuft.
Hat der denn ne IPv6 oder ne IPv4-Adresse?
Beides. Ok.
Dann müsstest du aber...
Und hängt der Raspberry Pi und der Rechner, von dem du darauf zugreifen willst, am gleichen Switch?
Oder halt an der gleichen Fritzbox?
Ja.
Dann solltest du zumindest, wenn du...
Mal hier...
IP-Add oder IF-Config machst...
Solltest du zumindest von deinem...
Achso ja, und dein Rechner braucht auch ne IPv6-Adresse.
Solltest du zumindest mit der Link-Local-FE80-Adresse drauf zugreifen können.
Du willst DNS machen.
Heißt im Endeffekt...
Wenn du DNS...
Also DNS mit...
Dünn-DNS und Gedöns machen willst...
Das bedeutet ja im Endeffekt dann...
Dass die Public IPv6-Adresse...
Von deinem Router...
Aufgelöst wird.
Also dass dein...
DNS-Name aufgelöst wird zu der Public IP von deinem Router.
Das heißt du brauchst auf jeden Fall, wenn du willst, dass das geht...
Eine...
Port-Weiterleitung.
Trotzdem, oder?
Oder?
Nee.
Brauchst du nicht, weil es gibt kein NAT.
Wie macht man das?
Wie macht man das eigentlich?
Äh, das ist ne gute Frage.
Gar nicht machst du das, ne?
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Weil IPv6, standardmäßig kein NAT.
Dementsprechend auch kein Port-Forwarding.
Heißt im Endeffekt...
Du brauchst ne Public IPv6-Adresse...
Auf deinem Raspberry Pi...
Und machst dann in deiner Router-Firewall...
Den Port frei und...
Machst nen statischen DNS-Eintrag...
Auf die...
IPv6-Adresse von deinem Router.
Aber das ist...
Das alleine bringt's dir ja nicht, ne?
Weil, wenn die IPv6 dynamisch ist...
Von der Fritzbox...
Und das dahinter...
Wie ist denn das überhaupt?
Wie macht...
Wie funktioniert denn das bei ner Fritzbox und IPv6?
Bekommen die Geräte dahinter...
Ne Public rootbare IPv6-Adresse?
Oder...
Machen die da...
Irgendwelche NAT-IPv6-Geschichten?
Du kannst ja entweder nur...
Dann geht auch Port-Weiterleitung.
Wenn Port-Weiterleitung nicht geht...
Dann ist da ne Firewall dazwischen.
Aber die Endgeräte kriegen Public IPs.
Wenn es Public IPs sind...
Dann...
Müsste erstmal die Firewall freigeschaltet werden auf dem Port.
Und...
Der DNS müsste die IP vom Raspberry Pi auflösen.
Nicht die Public IP von der Fritzbox.
Ich sag euch Leute...
Da sieht man wieder dran...
Wenn man nur an IPv6 gewöhnt ist...
Wenn man nur an IPv4 gewöhnt ist...
Das ist ganz schön umdenken angesagt bei IPv6.
Also ich denke es gibt zwei Varianten.
Entweder...
Hat dein Raspberry Pi...
Bekommt das eine gültige...
IPv6 Adresse.
Die rootbar ist im Internet.
Dann...
Kannst du es mit dünnen DNS vergessen.
Dann müsste dein Raspberry Pi...
Dünnen DNS machen und...
Seine IPv6 Adresse quasi...
Äh...
Announcen an den dünnen DNS.
Und nicht die Fritzbox IP.
Weil die Fritzbox IP...
Ist die Fritzbox IP.
Und da kommt man nicht bei deiner Nextcloud raus.
Also wenn das der Fall ist...
Dann kannst du den dünnen DNS Client...
Auf den Raspberry Pi drauf.
Und der Raspberry Pi...
Würde dann regelmäßig seine...
Seine public rootbare IPv6 Adresse...
Hinterlegen.
Unter diesem DNS Namen.
Dann müsstest du in deiner Fritzbox die Firewall freigeben.
Das...
Es erlaubt es vom Internet zuzugreifen...
Auf die IP...
Deines Raspberry Pis.
Nicht die Link Local.
Die public rootbare IPv6 Adresse des Raspberry Pis.
Müsstest du in der Fritzbox Firewall freigeben.
Sagen wir Port 443.
Das würde funktionieren.
Machen die IPv6...
Nutt auf der Fritzbox.
Wo ich keine Ahnung habe ob sie das machen.
Dann müsste es mit Port Weiterleitung...
Und dünnen DNS trotzdem funktionieren.
Wisst ihr was die machen?
Wahrscheinlich...
Machen die IPv6 Nutt oder so eklige...
Geschichten.
Ist echt nicht so ohne.
Ach guck mal hier gibt es...
Das hat er jetzt mit IPv6 nichts zu tun.
Ist das eine Firewall Freischaltung...
In Fritzbox Logik?
Ja da müsste man das wahrscheinlich da machen.
Wenn das statisch ist...
Dann kannst du auch einen statischen DNS setzen.
Aber die meisten...
Leute haben ja keine Public Domain...
Wo sie einen statischen DNS setzen können.
Du kannst über einen dünnen DNS Dienst...
Ja auch eine statische IP...
Setzen indem du immer die gleiche IP...
Announcest.
Der Slide ist doppeltes Nutt.
Nur bei IPv4 doppeltes Nutt.
Wir müssen erstmal rauskriegen wie das ist.
Guck nach.
Es ist eigentlich ganz easy rauszukriegen.
Guck nach was für IPadressen dein Raspberry Pi hat.
Dein Raspberry Pi sollte...
Ehm...
Mindestens mal eine IPv6...
Doch gibt es auch.
Dein Raspberry Pi...
Sollte eine interne IPv4 Adresse haben.
Wahrscheinlich.
Eine Link Local IPv6 Adresse.
Also eine die mit FE80 anfängt.
Und wenn dein Raspberry Pi zusätzlich...
Noch eine...
Noch eine andere IPv6 Adresse hat.
Außer diese FE80.
Dann hat er wahrscheinlich eine Public IP.
Guck dir mal an was dein Raspberry Pi...
Alles für IPs hat.
Hat er noch mehr als die FE80?
Probier es mal mit IPadd.
Anstatt mit ifconfig.
Falls du ifconfig nimmst.
IPadd zeigt manchmal mehr an.
Ja noch zwei weitere.
Das ist gut.
Dann hast du wahrscheinlich eine Public IPv6 Adresse.
Denke ich.
Ohne es zu wissen ehrlich gesagt.
Chat woran...
Habt ihr eine Ahnung woran man eine Public IPv6 Adresse...
Erkennen kann?
Wahrscheinlich einfach das sie nicht FE80 ist oder?
Ok die Fritzbox kann entweder...
Unique Local...
V6 verteilen.
Ok Unique Local bedeutet...
Du kriegst eine lokale IPv6 Adresse...
Die aber nicht ins Internet geroutet wird.
Ne?
Oder eine Global Unique V6 im internen Netz.
Aha.
Also Global Unique ist der Default.
Das heißt...
Standardmäßig müsste sein Raspberry Pi eine Internet routbare IPv6 haben.
Oder wie ist das?
Ok fängt mit 2001 an.
Kannst du uns mal die Anfänge deiner IPv6 Adressen posten?
Vielleicht haben wir ja irgendwelche High IQ Chat Leute.
Ich finde das Thema nämlich grad...
Ich wollte eigentlich schon vor 17 Minuten was voran gehen.
Kannst du uns mal die Anfänge deiner IPv6 Adressen posten?
Damit gibt ja genug Möglichkeiten.
Damit liegst du ja nix.
Und dann weiß der Chat ja vielleicht...
Was es ist.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich reim mir das grade so.
Ok FE80 weiß ich.
FE80 ist Link Local.
Ok 2FD00.
Wir googeln jetzt mal.
Kennzeichnet lokal generierte IP...
Adress-Types.
Aber ich dachte, die andere fangen mit
2001 an.
Achso, das ist das, was die Fritzbox
erkennt. Alter, meine
Güte, das ist so krass kompliziert.
Gestern im Stream
gab es Stellenbeschreibungen.
So erhalte ich zwei Adressen auf dem Subnet.
Das ist irgend so ein Vodafone-Ding,
oder? Ey, mach dir keine
Gedanken. Ich hab...
Du siehst, ich blick's auch nicht. IPv6 ist so
ein Ding, da hast du nicht viel, die da durchblicken.
Aber anscheinend ist das
irgendein Vodafone-Ding.
Also ich vermute
mal, ich vermute Folgendes.
Du kannst diese... Also was
auf jeden Fall gehen müsste, ist,
wenn du auf die FE80-Adresse
gehst von deinem Rechner aus.
Das ist Link-Log, das müsste funktionieren,
solange Nextcloud darauf
listen. Das müsste funktionieren. Das kannst du ja mal
ausprobieren. Wenn du auf die FE80-Adresse
gehst, Port 80, Port 443,
was auch immer da Nextcloud läuft,
das müsste auf jeden Fall funktionieren.
Ähm, diese 2A02,
das ist anscheinend
was aus dem Prefix von
Vodafone. Und da
bräuchte man wahrscheinlich
eine Firewall-Freischaltung
in der Fritzbox.
Dass das funktioniert.
Das würde ich als nächstes probieren, dann.
Und dann würde ich die DNS...
Dann würde ich den DNS-Eintrag machen.
So. Aber mehr können wir
jetzt echt nicht machen, weil...
...
Wir kommen ja nicht dran.
Wie gesagt, gestern war das mit stillen Anzeigen.
So, und jetzt muss ich echt was essen, Leute.
Wir sehen uns und hören uns. Ne, wir sehen uns nicht, wir hören uns nur.
Bis denn, macht's gut, Leute.
See you.